you
[Music]
you're listening to radio spudnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio welcome to the mother of
all talk shows the Open University of
the airwaves the College of knowledge
well there are no tuition fees and where
you are positively encouraged to speak
back to the teacher coronavirus raging
Donald Trump raving mad Boris Johnson
missing Joe Biden whimpering against the
dying of the light what could possibly
go wrong well just about everything that
could have gone wrong has gone wrong
particularly in the axis across the
Atlantic Donald Trump and Boris Johnson
in charge or are they and for how much
longer
certainly here in London mr. Johnson has
lost the confidence of mr. Rupert
Murdoch and has anyone in politics in
Australia in Britain maybe even in
America can tell you that is a dangerous
place to be we'll be talking to people
all around the world this evening
because this is the radio show with
pictures it's the place to be even now
you can encourage your friends family
followers contacts to tune in now fasten
your seat belt it's going to be a very
bumpy ride on the mother of all talk
shows radio Sputnik we speak your
language
mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get free
[Music]
George Galloway
this is radio Sputnik and this is London
but coming to you of course all over the
world thanks to the wonders of the
internet and Sputnik news calm
we're also on FM in the United States of
America 105.5 are the magic numbers
there and on AM coast-to-coast across
the United States but this is a radio
show with pictures and hundreds of
thousands of your half a million of you
we're watching as well as listening who
knows how many are merely listening half
a million of you are watching and here's
how you can do that you can watch on my
Facebook page George Galloway official
or on my youtube page ditto
George Galloway official now if you're
on my youtube channel click Subscribe
and wait in order to find out when we're
live change your notification priority
in the top right to all only then will
you be notified of new videos and
livestreams but if you don't want to go
on my facebook and my youtube well you
can do the same thing on Artie's
Facebook pages and Artie's YouTube pages
you can also watch on Twitter and even a
new innovation on Instagram as more and
more people extraordinarily are now
where to begin let's begin in the United
States I've followed Donald Trump's
tweets for a long time and they are
frequently unhinged green-ink capital
letter but this week when he called for
people to liberate one city after
another one state after another in his
own country of which he's the president
I thought that it was quite likely that
I'd hear the flap of white coats as they
came to take him away
I sensed from watching his
daily press conferences that he is
rapidly losing touch with reality you
may say he's never been now but I always
thought there was method in his madness
and I think I was right about that
I don't resolve from that but when you
are encouraging armed people onto the
streets of your own country I think that
country is in very serious trouble
indeed and I think the United States is
in very serious trouble
indeed it is now within a week it will
have a larger percentage of people
unemployed than it had at the height of
the Great Depression in the 1930s there
is going to be a terrible economic
hurricane in the United States in the
run-up to the presidential election in
ordinary circumstances that would mean
that Donald Trump was for the high jump
that would mean II actually needn't even
bother turning up in November for the
presidential election the economy ruined
unbelievable levels of sickness and
death in the communities across the
United States and I mean communities
these are not just numbers these are
cities these are blocks Brooklyn
thousands of people afflicted the Navajo
people the indigenous American people of
the Navajo have actually become close to
fearing that they will be wiped out by
the coronavirus those of them that won
wiped out when the white settlers came
and stole their land and killed them in
the first place the Navajo are amongst
the most afflicted affected people on
the entire earth but Donald Trump
throwing accusations around like billy-o
doesn't seem fazed why well one reason
has to be that the mental decline I used
to call it cognitive decline but I was
just being polite the mental
degeneration rapid mental decline of the
Democratic Party's candidate Joe Biden
must be of grave concern to anyone in
his family in his party in his country
this man simply will not be able to
stand a general election campaign
against a ruffian like Donald Trump
Donald Trump will not be polite he will
not even play with Joe Biden as the cat
plays with the mouse as a prelude to
killing it Donald Trump will tear Joe
Biden apart and therefore we have the
likelihood in my opinion I haven't seen
the bookmakers odds lately but the
likelihood of a man who has lost almost
all connection to reality with his
finger on the nuclear button in the
United States for another four and a
half years that is truly terrifying to
me and I think it ought to be to you
let's talk about China the United States
government has decided that as a
prophylactic - its own staggering levels
of inaction ineptitude it's staggering
levels of incompetence has decided to go
all out to blame China even though their
own chief medical officer continues to
contradict the president when he in an
increasingly bizarre way accuses China
of having let this whole monster loose
from a laboratory in Wuhan now I said
right at the beginning of this crisis
that the corona virus could have escaped
from a germ warfare lab
it could have escaped from the Chinese
germ warfare lab in Wuhan it could have
escaped from Fort Detrick in the United
States germ warfare lab it could have
been taken by the United States military
base right next to the Fort Detrick germ
warfare laboratory to Wuhan last
December for the military Games which
took place there it could be either of
those things but all of the science
accumulated to date makes clear that
actually the corona virus is a naturally
occurring virus a mutation of a
naturally or current virus that has
already visited us in times gone by a
mutation that makes it still more deadly
than it has ever been
the French government today denounced
Donald Trump's war mongering by saying
there was no evidence whatsoever that
this virus came from the germ warfare
laboratory in Wuhan if anyone's got any
evidence to the contrary let them
produce it but of course they haven't
they won't they can't because so far at
least it doesn't exist it's simply this
don't look at us in all our staggering
negligence and incompetence look over
there look at China and of course where
Washington goes the United Kingdom
follows this week the British government
announced a deep dive that was a new one
on me a deep dive inquiry into Britain's
relations with China and it will never
they said be business as usual
again well personally I hope the Chinese
have that loud and clear
I hope they concluded that these people
are not your friends these people are
not even reliable business partners and
according to the right-wing press this
weekend
the former decision to continue with who
are we in the 5g rollout is going to be
visited again and terminated look I hold
no candle for China I fly no Flags for
them I hardly know a single Chinese
person I haven't been in China for
decades I'm not here speaking for China
but it seems to me obvious that one of
the countries that has handled this
outbreak of in naturally occurring virus
best is China China and New Zealand and
South Korea and even Ireland have
handled this virus almost infinitely
better than the United States and Great
Britain have handled it and therefore I
conclude that the British and American
governments in order to try and divert
attention from their own failures their
own criminal negligence a point to which
I shall return are seeking to get up and
running a scare campaign a hate campaign
against China and I hope that China
draws the lesson from this as a matter
of fact be careful what you wish for
because if the Chinese would through
their investments from the United States
and Britain if the Chinese sold the
Treasury bonds that they hold for the
United States if the Chinese dumped the
dollar what would all go under pretty
damn quick so be careful what you wish
for
that's all I'm saying but today's Sunday
Times and today's sky news rapportage of
this crisis makes another thing
abundantly clear and that is the Boris
Jones
has lost the confidence of Rupert
Murdoch and that is a dangerous place
for any politician to be there's all-out
war now against Boris Johnson by his
erstwhile closest allies and it's not
hard to see that the man that Rupert has
anointed to take Boris Johnson's place
is little Michael Gove who is well how
shall I put it
pretty close his lips sucking on the
posterior of Rupert Murdoch and for a
very long time how do I know this
I follow the public prints and the
pronouncements of politicians and senior
media people very closely when I hear
Robert Peston of ITV claim that he's
gobsmacked to find how incompetent Boris
Johnson has turned out to be I say well
he's the very man that you did so much
to put into office and if you're
gobsmacked now is because you've been
encouraged to be gobsmacked for an
ulterior purpose an ulterior motive when
I see the journalists who did so much to
elect Boris Johnson's government now
turning on him with venom he's missed
skipped as the word they used not missed
he didn't miss five Cobra meetings
that's the underground Cabinet Office
briefing room a sounds more impressive
if you say Cobra the Cobra meetings were
the British state's inner sanctum meets
to handle emergencies were not missed by
Boris Johnson but skipped by Boris
Johnson five times it's abundantly clear
from the reportage particularly in the
Sunday Times today that the government
knew
the 500,000 people in Britain were
likely to die from the corona virus and
did absolutely nothing about it they did
nothing about buying the personal
protection equipment our frontline
services and then our secondary services
like bus drivers and jib staffs and so
on would have the necessary PPE they did
nothing to secure the number of
ventilators that we would need they did
nothing for months it's now clear to
prepare a response to an emergency which
they themselves had concluded during a
drill for this in 2016 would quickly
overwhelm the National Health Service
operation Cygnus 2016 October war gamed
an invasion by a flu-like virus coming
from East Asia and they concluded that
they could not publish the results of
the war game because it was and I quote
truly terrifying some people said it was
a threat to quote national security to
list the results of the operation Cygnus
so they knew from 2016 when incidentally
Jeremy Hunt who is now scuttling around
the TV studios obliquely blaming his
successors for their failures Jeremy
Hunt was the health secretary at the
time but never mind
Cygnus we knew from January that this
was coming our way and our government
not only did nothing to save us they
deliberately did nothing because it's
now as plain as a pikestaff their policy
war
herd immunity their purpose was for us
all to get it and let the devil take the
weak and the old many of whom had voted
for Boris Johnson just last December to
put him in power in the first place
it's quite clear that the death toll in
Britain is going to be the highest in
all of Europe it might even be the case
that the British death toll is second
highest in the whole world with the
United States as the highest now if that
fills you with confidence in the two
blonde bombshell's in power in
Washington and London well good luck to
you in Ward 5 in Broadmoor but for the
rest of us we have to conclude that our
governments our state's our societies
are not fit for the purpose of defending
our people against our real enemies are
not fit for the purpose of providing
work and food and shelter for our own
people we are led by dangerous fools
dangerous knaves that's really the
question you have to work out now we've
got a poll running well Boris Johnson
survived the coronavirus by which I
don't mean he'll have a relapse amidst
his 1,500 acres in checkers where he's
recuperating no I mean will the
Conservative MPs be rid of Boris Johnson
before this coronavirus is over answer a
yes B no fasten your seatbelts it's the
mother of all talk shows
radio Sputnik
[Music]
tune in every Tuesday - loud and clear
for a regular segment called false
prophets a weekly look at Wall Street
and corporate capitalism where we talk
about the big economic issues of the
week from the point of view of working
people the poor and the u.s. position in
the global economy join us this Tuesday
and every Tuesday with financial policy
analyst Daniel Sankey right here on
radio Sputnik want to talk get in touch
with us at radio at Sputnik news calm we
are talking twenty four hours a day
seven days a week you are listening we
give you the most essential out of the
endless information space radio Sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm 24 hours a
day seven days a week we give you the
most essential information out there
radio Sputnik telling the untold George
Galloway and the mother of old talk
shells and join us at the College of
knowledge where there are no tuition
fees no it's a close-run thing but the
United States is definitely in the
deepest trouble over the coronavirus not
just because it has vastly the largest
number of cases by a very considerable
distance the worst rate of death from
the coronavirus but its political
structures are not just creaking at the
seams they are actually falling apart
governors are attacking the president
the president is attacking the
governor's the president is tweeting the
armed people should advance upon the one
I saw was Virginia but there have
apparently been many others liberate
Virginia he said encouraging the gun
owners of America to head into the
streets in Michigan I saw thousands of
people demanding that the lockdown be
lifted the lockdown on the placards
being equal to communism that's how deep
the sickness runs in the United States
of America so we've got Donald Trump
raving mad at the podium and the White
House and Joe Biden simpering in what
seems to be semi imbecilic terms I don't
know in some Darby and Joan home
somewhere I have no idea where he is
what I do know is he's not all there
wherever he is
Rania Khalek is law the wonderful
journalist presenter and writer and she
joins me by Skype right now from the
United States Rania welcomed by - oh now
I really don't mean to be kind my great
grandmother was in America
I've got American blood in my veins but
your country is in one hell of a mess
when the president is in
armed insurrection on the streets of his
own country and living almost
unprecedented ly at the dispatch box or
at the podium in the press room every
single day I fear for the future of your
country deal yeah George it's surreal
what's taking place right now in some
ways it's not surprising because
everything in America is so politicized
and we have elections in November so
everything the president says and does
right now is about trying to win that
election the election has already
started and in the process what he's
doing is insane you have a bunch of dark
money Republican groups combined with a
mix of right-wing militias that are
holding these anti lockdown protests
like you mentioned comparing lockdowns
to communism and it's being encouraged
by the president and it's extremely
dangerous you have hundreds of people
crowding together in the midst of a
pandemic where you have a highly
infectious respiratory violated virus
it's killing people that spreads from
person to person and as you can see we
have the highest infection rate in the
u.s. we have our hospitals right now are
completely overwhelmed we don't have
enough protective equipment for our
health care workers it's a complete
disaster and these people are going to
infect each other they're gonna go and
infect other people and they're gonna
help overwhelm our hospitals even more
and that is at the encouragement of the
country's president who is now
redirecting all of the outraged against
himself for being so willfully
unprepared for this pandemic by you know
you know invoking this foreign boogeyman
of China and both parties are playing
into it now it's a complete disaster but
at the same time you know unemployment
in America is soaring we have 22 million
people that we know of unemployed in the
last four weeks and the government is
doing very very little to help actual
Americans and so at this point I don't
want to be alarmist but I do fear in
certain parts of the country you're
gonna see a real societal breakdown
and these protests with people waving
their guns and just saying the most
idiotic things and it's likely infecting
each other is kind of just the beginning
of it well I think you expressed all
that perfectly and we're gonna seal that
in an inner tube and send out to the
world but let's uh break down the
different parts of this the governor of
Florida reopened Florida's beaches and
of course predictably thousands of
people headed for the beaches inches
feet at most apart the the protests in
Michigan
these are armed people I mean this is
not the Congo we're talking about here
this is the United States of America
supposedly the leader of the free world
this is the richest and most powerful
country on the earth
containing the power to annihilate the
earth in its nuclear arsenal and we've
got a man who's standing there daily
with millions of people watching them
encouraging the most incredibly
irresponsible behavior how are the
Democrats responding to this it's really
shocking because you know right now is
an opportunity politically for Democrats
to come in and say you know what here's
what we need to deal with this crisis
and instead they're kind of just useless
I mean you do have real pain these are
silly and idiotic and dangerous as these
anti lockdown protests are they are
tapping into a rage that's only going to
grow in America because like I mentioned
22 million people unemployed every other
wealthy country in the world is doing
something to prevent complete and total
economic collapse and the failure of all
their businesses by taking over the
payroll responsibilities so people
aren't unemployed and can still afford
groceries by giving people checks every
month what is the u.s. doing it's given
people twelve hundred dollar checks over
the course of four months many people
haven't even been able to access that
money it hasn't for
and rents their mortgages it's pitiful
the richest country in the world isn't
taking care of its own people so you're
gonna see a lot of rage and legitimate
grievances by people who do need to put
a roof over their head and feed their
families and so that's why I say it's an
opportunity for Democrats to come in and
say you know what this is a time we need
universal health care this is a time
when we should be taking over the
payroll like we've seen a lot of
European countries of small businesses
and keeping them afloat and keeping
money in people's pockets and instead
what we see from Democrats is really
pathetic ideas like let's stuff like
they want to subsidize private health
insurance for people right now that's a
democratic idea it's pathetic
it's absolutely pathetic and it's not
gonna you know speak to the grievances
that people have and what that means is
that they're ceding the ground to the
right to come in with all these insane
conspiracy theories and say you know
what go protests the lockdown
that's the issue the issue is the
lockdown not the fact that your
government and the leaps in this country
aren't taking care of you and are giving
corporate bailouts to all these massive
companies that don't even pay taxes I
mean it's just utterly shocking and you
know what you do have to as you know a
couple like last week Nancy Pelosi the
you know the leader of the Democrats in
Congress did it you know did like a
little funny interview where she was
sitting in front of her refrigerators
for two massive refrigerators my god was
the biggest freezer visit seen luxury
refrigerators bragging about all the
chocolate she has in her freezer I mean
this is a hundred millionaire leader of
the Democratic Party and this is all she
has to offer it was a daddy it was a
Marie Antoinette moment wasn't it really
was and I think at the end of the day
this is going to be really devastating
politically for the Democrats and I
think you're gonna see Republicans win
out as a result like I think we're
looking at a situation where we're
likely gonna have a second term of
Donald Trump and that's a disaster but
you really I mean who can you blame who
could the Democrats blame they had an
opportunity and they're squandering it
by giving us Joe Biden a corporate hack
who can't even form a coherent sentence
who's completely uninspiring as
the option against Donald Trump I mean
we're just in this country we're headed
for disaster it's it's a scary moment
yeah of course you're societal breakdown
and the mass poverty and unemployment of
your own people
disastrous tragic though that is is a
matter for you
what is more worrying for the world is
that whereas before the Democrats hated
Russia and the Republicans hated China
now both of them hate China and war with
China is not actually an impossibility
now you may say I'm being alarmist but
it seems to me the logical conclusion
ineluctable I see Bannon shouting for it
on the TV today is a drive to isolate
and sanction and and quarantine China in
a way that may very well lead to actual
war which means world war are people
really serious about this Rania I don't
know if there's so much serious about
world war but they're certainly serious
about coming up with justifications for
more bloated military budgets and of
course whenever you escalate we were
already on a path to a new cold war with
China that was happening before
coronavirus coronavirus of course has
accelerated that because what you have
is this rising supercut you know this
rising new power China that really does
you know pose a threat to us you know
dominance over the whole globe as its
had for the last 20 or so years and so
that you know scares American elites so
we've already been on that path but what
right now I think what you're seeing is
an attempt by Donald Trump to redirect
all of the outrage at him for really you
know botching the response to
coronavirus at China and it's working if
you look at the polls of most Americans
in both parties they blame China they're
angry at China they're like basically
primed to support any sort of war
whether it's a proxy war or
war against China and then what you have
in the Democrats is rather than saying
okay let's be the adults in the room
this is insane you have them trying to
out hawk Trump on China as we've seen in
the last couple days with John with Joe
Biden unveiling his campaign strategy of
saying oh do you know Donald Trump is to
pro-china and he let the Chinese you
know have too much influence and so it's
gonna it's very dangerous of course like
you mentioned for the world and
internally in the u.s. it's at the end
of the day this is like a completely
racist narrative that's actually
impacting asian-americans across the
u.s. we've seen hate crimes against
asian-americans go up and for any of us
to remember the feelings and you know
after 9/11 and in the lead up to the
Iraq war and in the years after the
whole war on terror you feel something
really familiar here it's like it's like
the new the you know the war on terror
has shifted to a war on China all the
talking points have shifted to China's a
part of the axis of evil and you know
the big evil Chinese you know Yellow
Peril Menace is like the new big bad
Muslims and so if you see that what you
know could the kind of toll that's had
on the world the last 20 years you can
imagine how much more devastating it
will be to have this accelerated
escalation between the US and China
going forward yeah because China will
fight back of course I made the point
out be careful what you wish for if
China decided to drop the dollar move to
the euro or abandon reserve currencies
altogether if China decided to dump the
US debt that it owns the Treasury bonds
and so on your 22 million unemployed
would pale into insignificance to the
economic crash that you would have then
and if they did so the danger of a hot
war would of course exponentially
increase right I mean yeah that's a good
point to make because in the in the past
I mean with the targets of American
imperialism being countries like
Afghanistan or Iraq these were very weak
countries that didn't have the resources
of their capabilities to fight back
China is not a weak country it's a
growing power
that has a very powerful economy and
that's able to really handle its own so
the US isn't picking a fight with
someone who can't fight back they're
picking a fight would start with a
powerful country which make us makes it
all the more dangerous but I think also
what you're gonna see with all this is
everything you just mentioned the u.s.
in a way the u.s. is so dependent on
China economically that there's only so
much the US can do without severe
consequences so I think you know what
you're also gonna see is because of the
corona virus and this accelerating cold
war we've already seen it partly with
the trade war is you're gonna see it
really not only impact the American
economy but impact the standard of
living in America I think that this has
really accelerated what was already
taking place which was the decline of US
Empire and you're seeing that play out
internally as well so it's like in this
case you know a war with China isn't
gonna be America coming out on top and
just crushing its enemy but how that
plays out in the rest of the world too
it could lead to a lot of proxy wars as
well it's it's we don't know but it's
definitely a dangerous escalation the
rhetoric in America is extremely
dangerous and no one's speaking out
against it and just to if you want to
measure the decline when I first became
politically conscious it was in a
general election between President Jack
Kennedy and also President Richard Nixon
and now the dichotomy is Joe Biden and
Donald Trump just think about that all
of us need to just think about that
Rania Khalek as always thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the mother
of all talk shows fantastic picture that
Rania painted there now Dakota says time
for the headmaster at the mote
University the only bloke who's got the
most formidable knowledge that I know
Parliament needs to have him back now
more than ever
Thank You Dakota Sampson says China is
to blame for allowing those wet markets
to carry on knowing the risks after
and h1n1 if they can lock down a city
they can lock down those markets you
know they're farmers markets Samson
right you know the kind of things that
Guardian readers just love when they
visit other countries or even the
countryside in our own Peter says good
evening George
thanks for keeping the show going
through this bizarre time is the is a
highlight of the week and the Sunday air
timeslot in my opinion gives the show
more gravitas than the Friday slot thank
you
Carlo says thinking of everyone affected
by this terrible virus sending out
caring thoughts to you all and on
facebook dave says our hospitals here in
the UK are so empty that the NH staff
NHS staff are always outside dancing
lobby game was it that hung up and ran
away last week on the show Julie says
what do you think about building sites
in London being open for business
tomorrow with unite the Union calling
for staggered start and finishing times
I've often wondered how completing a new
high-rise building in the center of
London was in any way essential work and
will as a Canadian I'm scared to death
of another four years of Trump David I'm
ready to listen to someone with honesty
compassion and common sense good evening
Gigi thanks Dave
barb says were surrounded by crazies in
the United States kevin says we don't
need a vaccine the virus has to make its
way through eighty percent will have
little or no sickness now hard luck if
you're in the 20% give and the emails
are coming in too if you were put in
charge of captain Tom Moore's 26 million
pounds raised for the NHS how would you
spend it a good question I'll ruminate
on that and come back to it and here's
another one I wanted to get your take on
the fact sir kia has been pushing her
majesty's government for an
exit strategy which you agree or
disagree it's actually saving people's
lives right now in hospital wards on
buses on tubes that I'm more worried
about than an exit strategy but then I'm
one of these weirdos that thinks human
life is more important than pound
shillings and pence now earlier in the
week my good wife all of our own in our
garden shot our weekly short for our tea
it's going great guns it may actually be
one of the biggest of all the shots that
we have done in terms of audience take a
look at it the leaked labor report is
devastating confirmation of a four and a
half year conspiracy against Jeremy
Corbyn
[Music]
though you won't know about it unless
you watch and read RT and follow social
media all those political journalists
and broadcasters who throughout the
entire period of jeremy corbyn's
leadership crawled incessantly through
the entrance of internal labor politics
have completely ignored a report which
seems to establish the biggest scandal
in the labor parties more than 100 year
history the report reveals that the most
senior levels in the Labor Party's
headquarters a conspiracy was afoot
right from day one a conspiracy to
undermine carbons leadership and
ultimately to throw the general election
of 2017 when Corbin came less than three
thousand votes away from forming
Britain's first ever socialist
government it's alleged in the report
that they diverted funds to their
favourite right-wing Blair I candidates
and choked funds and activity in the
constituencies of Corbin supporting
candidates it is full of racist juvenile
misogynistic abuse of carbon and his
supporters it talks about how it would
be to watch Jeremy Corbyn set on fire it
talks about people being taken up
against a wall and shot yet none of the
British media find any of this remotely
interesting enough even for a footnote
imagine if this was a Corbin
headquarters talking in such a way about
their internal party rivals most
importantly of all it seems to indicate
as many of us argued throughout
that the vial poison of anti-semitism
was deliberately weaponized inflated
enlarged exaggerated and sat on in order
to provide the maximum conditions to
damage their own leader and of course
worse than that to damage the whole
concept of anti-semitism itself
anti-semitism is the most vile form of
racism because in the lifetime of some
people still around today it caused the
mass mother and extermination of 6
million Jews in Europe and it would have
continued except that the Red Army
liberated the camps those implicated are
of the highest level in labor politics
some of them continue to hold extremely
high strategically important positions
in British politics
some of them sit in air mine in the
House of Lords nominated ironically by
Jeremy Corbyn himself I want to put it
this way the idea that the Corbin
conspiracy was merely the product of
very rotting apples in a barrel in the
Labour Party headquarters is profoundly
wrong these people didn't just hate
Corbin and what he stood for these
people stood for something else they
were not followers of Jeremy Corbyn but
they were followers of someone else of
something else they were working for
someone for something if you want to
know who I think that's something that
someone really was ask yourself this who
benefits from the destruction of a
potential Labour government which would
now be three years in power think how
different life would have been for tens
millions of people in Britain if Corbin
had got that extra two thousand seven
hundred votes in 2017 who benefits the
same people who've always benefited from
right-wing pronate or pro-american
politics inside the labor movement they
hated Corbin not because he wanted to
put tuppence on the income tax they
hated Corbin because he just might
follow a different foreign policy to
that which labour has always followed
before Tony Blair is the architect of
the great labor scandal and it's Tony
Blair and his friends who are now in
charge of the Labour Party after all who
is secure starmon
except Tony Blair without the laughs
have something to say do you disagree
with George then call us now and give us
your view now the polls running running
fast will Boris Johnson survive as prime
minister after the coronavirus a yes 56%
be no 44% quite close vote now on my
Twitter feed 706 votes so far Salah from
Birmingham his online one bath take him
Salah go ahead hello hello by the grace
of God I'm good thanks for calling what
would you like to say I'd like to say
yours you claim to be a supporter of
Palestine I was bidding palms and he
supported half the amount of money
backing in the past and yet a few weeks
ago one of the other pelvis to came on
the phone and complained about the way
the kind of political Muslims come there
there is no doubt there is a lot of
evidence online on various field offices
both laughing and writing and yes sir
you've denied it aren't you supposed to
be first of all I'm absolutely guilty of
being left-wing and secondly I don't
claim to be a supporter of
Palestinian people I am as a cursory
glance at my life's work would make
clear and you are phrasing in that way
is deeply offensive and insulting to me
thirdly I am not now nor have I ever
been a supporter of Hamas not now not
then not in the future
I have never supported Hamas so now that
we've got the furniture that you
deliberately placed around the issue out
of the way let's deal with the issue the
phantom phantom of Chinese persecution
of millions of Muslims in the same gang
region of China is just that it's a
phantom it is got up by the same people
who told you that the Falun Gong
religious fanatic organization is
somehow representative of the Chinese
people the same people that claim that
the Dalai Lama should be ruling the
Chinese region of Tibet the same people
who are now telling you that the Chinese
deliberately engineered the coronavirus
and sent it our way having lost are
comparatively few of their own number
and they rely on fools like you Salah
they rely on you like Pavlov's dogs and
they you know they won't come to you
with the story of the following gong
because your name is Salah from
Birmingham they go somewhere else would
the following Gong story they won't come
to you looking for support for the Dalai
Lama because your name is Salah in
Birmingham they come to you with the
Weger phantom story precisely because
they know that you are fertile ground
for that conspiracy theory no lastly
again you lied your way on to this show
by claiming that you wanted to speak
about 5g being rolled out in the United
Kingdom
so you're the second person in two weeks
to lie about what they actually wanted
to speak about on the show so let me
hear what you've got to say and then be
gone
go ahead last what do you Salah yes I
think you are they your liquidizer hold
on hold on you really think that I'm a
left-wing sympathizer why you are
Einstein you are the smartest man on the
globe you really think that I am a
left-wing sympathizer
is the Pope a Catholic do bears defecate
in the woods
what made you ever think that I was not
a left-wing sympathizer have you been
away for a long stretch like the last 40
years can I speak now yes okay well like
I said I'm not denying the fact that
you've always been sympathize what I'm
saying is all of impartiality run out of
the window when you when you speak when
will you talk about the Palestinian
standard because but you like to us to
China China have life so can I write
about the number this week that that
actually increased the numbers increase
numbers Salah we've all increased our
numbers China have increased their
numbers but a lot fewer than we have
because because we've just discovered
that we weren't counting the human
beings dying in care homes so our number
have increased also 50% perhaps greater
than the hospital rate of death but I
want to ask you something was I telling
the truth about the Palestinians or not
you know your emphasis on the
Palestinians is dependent on the
left-wing government
otherwise you would love important Salah
our Hamas a left-wing government they've
got left redundancies yes you're some
joke are you the islamic resistance in
Palestine has left-wing tendencies
absolutely sorry sir I can't continue
you're actually bonkers let me hear from
Eric in Vancouver go ahead Eric hello
George how are you doing I'm good my
Bloods pumping hard don't know that I
was five minutes ago go ahead
that was quite that was quite living to
hear yeah great to hear you on the air
broadcasting your proper English thank
you the pleasure to the year let me tell
you thank you so much well George I
think we are dealing with a serious
malnutrition malnutrition boarded
incomplete information yeah the surgeon
was daily as if it were a full meal and
by an incompetent and non enquiring
media not specifically I would say there
is almost like a de facto D notice
operated in the United States regarding
the Kogan virus when no one in the
mainstream or even alternative media
very much will you interview true
objective experts on bioweapons that are
not already connected to that industry I
mean most of the people that are up
there according to dr. Boyle who I'll
get to in a moment
or are already deep deep involved with
that you know we've spoken before Eric
you you're one of those who suspects
that this corona virus is a bio weapon
yeah yes I do because there's a lot of
that effect but you have to be perhaps
though scientists to agree to understand
that that happens to be my background
what do you make of the French
government's statement on this today you
know I didn't hear that could you tell
me the French say there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever there what's that
will mind battery coronavirus originated
in the bio weapons lab in Wuhan well
that reminds me of your great hero
Coburn what was his first name clock
Coburn yeah
the journalist who said don't believe
anything is still officially denied by
the government yeah yeah nothing is
until it's officially denied well let's
let's work with your hypothesis all
right what so presumably you imagine
then that this was a bio weapon which
was accidentally released am i right I
think that's uh quite possible yes I
don't think it was purposely released
personally I think there's any evidence
of that fact but I think that the big
takeaway I hope from this call is that
you should get dr. Francis Boyle in the
interview him I mean this is a guy who's
been there he'd see an officer as you
know public law 101 298 United States
the Bionic people he's an admirable man
we'll definitely try and do that Chris
if you're listening ears must let's try
and get dr. Francis Boyle I know I'm
I've met them he's he's a so that will
be an interview what do you think I said
from the beginning fact I made a whole
program about on Cal Imahara on our my
Dean television that of course the the
corona virus could be man-made
it could be man-made and released by
accident it could be man-made and
released deliberately it could be
man-made in China or in the United
States what's your what's your current
thinking the evidence is outlined in at
least three different articles but in
particular the one in nature magazine
that we talked about before
like December 2015 title the article
through your listeners look up as SARS
like cluster of circulating Beth coroner
virus proposed threat for human
emergence and one of the authors of that
article which the researchers talking
about it's at the University of North
Carolina was it was a doctor generally
Elise Shem he is the director of the
Wuhan BSL level for laboratory which has
four documented previous leaks of lethal
pathogens including an earlier stars
episode this kind of information you're
going to get if you talk to dr. Boyle
about I already knew that I also know
that the Fort Detrick American bio
weapons laboratory had so many accidents
that they pulls it down
that's right looked that way from what
happened last summer yes there's a lot
of illness in the area of the lab before
the shutdown happened and the and the
military athletes that went to war on
for the military games late last year
came from the Fort Dietrich area I
didn't know that that's interesting
interesting to say the least
thank you we'll try and get Francis
Boyle on I promise you that thanks very
much again for the call let's squeeze in
Joshua in London before the break go
ahead Joshua you're right George
yes by the grace of God I'm good thank
you yeah I was just wondering what are
your sort of thoughts on how the
Scottish government has come to rest I
mean any any particular thought well
they've handled that just about as badly
as the UK government has handled a small
businesses are crying out for the
financial assistance for which the
Scottish government were given the money
by London and the main takeaway I have
from the Scottish government so-called
response to this whole thing is that
they are trying to use it to further
divide the peoples of this small island
by falsely early
that somehow England is being
prioritized over Scotland in the
allocation of money and resources
medical equipment and so on so have you
got a better take on that well in my
opinion in my opinion like they would
seem to be doing a slightly better job
but then you got issues like uh
population density which is that much
faster in Scotland than in most of
England and white well it could scarcely
be more sparse we have five million
people in in a country as big as England
and the England in the same space I
think that he can bear a head start on
that but they've had to fire their chief
medical officer that's failing to follow
her own advice so that isn't
praiseworthy Nicola Sturgeon the First
Minister tried very hard to hold on to
her chief medical officer even though
that CMO had been captured
twice disobeying the very things that
she was demanding the public in Scotland
shouldn't do namely
traveling hundreds of miles to her
holiday home at weekends your mind you
sorted sort of Prince Charles and
Camilla they also they also broke the
rules yeah no I mean if if Russia has
the best way adapt hold two and a half
times smaller than Scotland even though
that has a population of 30 times large
and nearly then while I think they come
a bit of better a bit better than Boris
John and the Scottish government yeah
they're not getting they're not
deserving of any real praise well
anymore the freezer yeah the fridge
doing a little bit better than Boris
Johnson will soon come historically to
be the very definition of faint praise
thanks Joshua for that call I'm
go to Jamie Lowe who did a great job
last week with the news I'll be right
back after this bulletin curious about
our curricula have something to say then
call us now to join the debate on the
mother of all talk shows with George
Galloway tune in every Tuesday to loud
and clear for a regular segment called
false prophets a weekly look at Wall
Street and corporate capitalism where we
talk about the big economic issues of
the week from the point of view of
working people the poor and the u.s.
position in the global economy join us
this Tuesday and every Tuesday with
financial policy analyst Daniel Sankey
right here on radio Sputnik it's time to
double down with Max and Stacey yeah
double down we're talking markets
finance business economics to change
bling just about everything money
related on Sputnik it's called double
down we're asking our dead cats bouncing
or have fundamentals change that's this
week and double down
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news some of the biggest
names in music have joined forces to
celebrate healthcare workers in a
globally televised concert Lady gaga
Paul McCartney and Billy Eilish were
among more than a hundred artists who
performed songs from their living rooms
jutted the coronavirus locked down the
Rolling Stones
even managed to play together from four
separate locations the 8-hour show also
featured real-life stories from those on
the front line of the fight against
covert 19 Lady Gaga who created the
lineup called the event a love letter to
the world titled one world together at
home the concert was organized by the
global citizen movement and the World
Health Organization proceeds generated
from the concert or go to The Cove it 19
so Ladera t response Fund for the w-h-o
but Lady Gaga made clear that the show
was not a fundraising telephone and
would focus on entertainment and
messages of solidarity however so far
it's raised more than 128 million
dollars in Britain BBC One is screening
excerpts of the concert and they will
also introduce extra performances from
British artists and stories from
frontline workers in the UK Spanish
children who have been kept at home
since the 14th of March under strict
measures to curb the spread of KO bida
19 will at last be able to see the
outside world later this week
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez aimed to
relax the lockdown rules on April the
27th so that they can get some fresh air
as he put it
Spain has seen more than 20,000 deaths
since the start of the pandemic and
almost 200,000 reported cases in a
televised briefing Sanchez said Spain
had left behind the most extreme moments
and contained the brutal onslaught of
the pandemic the number of kovat 19
patients who've died in UK hospitals has
risen to 16,000 and 60 that's an
increase of 596 in 24 hours down from
the previous daily death toll of 888
however these figures do not include
those who've died in care homes or in
the community and are likely to be at
least 50%
professor Sara Gilbert who's leading a
team developing a vaccine at your Oxford
University said that they are hoping to
start clinical trials towards the end of
next week but nobody could be sure it
was possible to find a workable vaccine
she said that they would need government
support to accelerate manufacturing
because the UK currently does not have
the facilities to make the vaccine on a
large scale Germany's Health Minister
says that the month-long lockdown has
brought his country's coronavirus break
under control
yen span said since April the 12th the
number of recovered patients had been
consistently higher than the number of
new infections the infection rate has
dropped to naught point seven that is
each infected person passed the virus to
fewer than one other in Germany three
thousand eight hundred and sixty eight
have died of koban nineteen fewer than
in Italy Spain France and the UK New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo has signed an
order allowing online marriages as many
weddings have been canceled under
lockdown restrictions from now on people
in the US state will be able to apply
for marriage licenses remotely and
carked allowed to conduct ceremonies
virtually Cuomo joked that the decision
meant that there was no excuse for
couples to not tie the knot the decision
comes after New York State extended
lockdown measures until May 15 more than
13,000 people have died of coronavirus
in New York City alone Israel is facing
the growing prospect of an unprecedented
fourth election in just over a year
after a deadline two former government
has expired its president passed the
mandate to Parliament after the
center-left locked leader Benny Ganz
failed to seal talks to form a unity
government in time if no one else gets
nominated within 21 days new elections
will be held by August the fourth and
finally captain Tom more than 99 year
old who's raised more than 25 million
for the National Health Service in the
UK by walking around his garden has
released a charity single which has gone
to number one in the iTunes chart the
track you'll never walk alone which Tom
Moore recorded with Michael Ball has
pushed Dame Vera Lynn and Katherine
Jenkins duets have we'll meet again to
but to the 1945 rodgers and hammerstein
song from the musical carousel will
raise money for the NHS alongside
captain moore's ongoing walking appeal
it's become an anthem for medical staff
during the corona virus pandemic the new
version features an introduction from
Tom Moore who says when you walk through
a storm hold your head up high and don't
be afraid of the dark more maybe 99 but
the woman he beat to number one Dame
Vera is still alive at 103 years old the
forces sweetheart Dame Vera had entered
the charts just a few days before with
the re-release of her wartime
inspirational song which first came out
in 1939 that's put nick use by Jamie
Lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
the untold welcome to the Open
University of the airwaves with George
Galloway only on Sputnik radio will
Boris Johnson survivors prime minister
after the coronavirus a yes sixty
percent up for be no forty percent down
for you can vote now on my Twitter feed
at George Galloway 1118 votes so far
you've got till nine o'clock to have
your say on that on my Twitter feed now
Italy of course has suffered
extraordinary agony in the time of the
corona the death toll in Italy remains
the highest in Europe though it is
rapidly being overtaken by our own here
in Britain it's often said that Italy is
two weeks ahead of Britain on the curve
one man who's been writing about the
situation there is Nicolas Paolo he's a
journalist and an author based in Italy
and he's been good enough to join us by
Skype this evening
Nicolas thank you very much indeed for
joining us first of all give us an
update will you on what the current
situation in the country is well what is
it a hundred and twenty thousand people
infected and what is it sixteen thousand
dead I think the British well only a
very bit Nicolas I'm sorry I was just
going to say given the Italians are too
civilized to put their own mother in a
care home most old people in Italy are
living with their families we on the
other hand have massive numbers of
people in care homes and we've now
discovered belatedly that they are Riven
with the coronavirus so actually if you
add
British hospital dead to the care home
dead and the at home dead we're already
ahead of Italy shortly
well yes if that if those figures are
true I mean what is it seven thousand in
the care homes and fifteen thousand in
the hospitals that makes what is it
twenty two thousand yeah dead in England
but I mean the other question here of
course is how come nobody in Germany is
dying and also why you know what what a
lot of the well I don't know I can't
remember I was gonna say but anyway I
mean how do we how do we know how many
people have got the damn virus that's
the trouble
yeah I reckon I had in January well the
answer to your question about Germany is
surely this that the German Health
Service is better than the Italian and
better than the British that the German
mmm I think that I'm not so sure about
that really I think what they did yeah
maybe you're right but I think what they
did which nobody else really did was
they did lots and lots of testing right
from the start so they could then find
out who had the virus and were able to
isolate them that's what the WHI told
everyone to do in January testing they
were distinct testing the the leader of
the WH all said but the rest of us
didn't do it the Germans did it New
Zealand has done it with such
spectacular effect that I think that no
one has died in New Zealand they locked
down immediately they tested a
staggering number something like 1500
people per million they did a staggering
number of tests then they isolated the
people that were positive and tracked
their contacts and thus
by some miracle they've been spared why
didn't our governments do that well yeah
well that's a very good question but I
mean but I mean partly because they just
do not have the ability to do that they
do not have the the tests for a start
but not just that they don't have the
laboratories available to process all
those that huge number of tests that's
the problem it's a logistical thing too
in terms of from the lack of
laboratories not not just lack of tests
but lack of laboratories I mean you know
only a country like only a country like
Germany what was had the ability to do
that because it's I think Germany or
South Korea or New Zealand it's come to
something Nikolas hasn't it when when
Britain and Italy respectively the sixth
and seventh richest economy in the world
is unable to do such a basic thing when
a much predicted often heralded pandemic
virus heads their way well okay but I
mean I mean I don't think anyone's come
out of this smelling of roses have they
known no single country really well you
would argue the Far East countries have
arguing unarguably that New Zealand has
the best record in the entire world well
you know about New Zealand I don't but I
mean I'll take your word for it I mean
the yeah but the thing is I mean we
everybody's talked about that this his
gut was going to happen sooner or later
no such a pandemic as this and and yet
of course no be really prepared for it
except I mean okay New Zealand is a
smaller country isn't it so the other
thing is that well I don't know quite
I'm sorry I I'm not aware of the New
Zealand example we've obviously
heard it and I haven't but I mean I I
know about the Far East but there you
see you're talking about a different
approach to the freedom of the
individual for example let's go to that
the the implication of what you're
saying is that places like Singapore
South Korea China did what they did
because of the political systems that
they have though I think South Korea's
political systems pretty similar to
Italy's and Britain's is it not well
depends how you define these things I
mean a lot of people are having a go at
all bands Hungary no because he's the
virus has given him an excuse to become
a dictator but the fact is that in Italy
the government is ruling by decree not
by parliamentary vote and nobody raises
an eyebrow so you know there's a lot of
[ __ ] talked about who is a dictator
and who isn't but I suspect that in the
far east there is a different attitude
to the individual and liberty compared
to the West especially the British
anglo-saxon West British an American
Angus action West and for example I
think they think the rights of the
community are stronger than the rights
of the individual and so therefore it's
far easier to introduce such lockdowns
you know really stringently
and a math test people quickly and wet
stuff and then if they're you know a lot
come away if they're positive well I
think that's an important philosophical
question that you have raised I don't
think they mean I don't think the
evidence fits your dichotomy I think
your dichotomy is somewhat false one and
I gave two of the reasons why New
Zealand and South Korea are not remotely
communist or socialist or collectivist
societies but let me
ask your Nikolas how is it impacted the
political scene in Italy you make the
point the government is ruling by decree
no one's raising an eyebrow that's
happened in Italy before of course but
the point is are they doing a good job
or not is the government being
strengthened by the job that it's doing
or weaker well mmm it's very difficult
to say but the the the polls such as
they are reveal that the that the the
premier who of course is not even an MP
or anything an elected MPs brought in as
a compromise candidate in 2018
he is extremely popular but on the other
hand I mean how are they handling it
well not very well you know you talk
about that the intervention of the
states to help the citizen being vital
in these situations I mean I certainly
think that is the case should be the
case you know that is only the state
that can save the country and you know
in England with massive amounts of money
are being sloshed about offered here
there and everywhere in Italy it's all
just peanuts basically I mean I'd love
that I'm a father of six I've got six
children age 16 down to four all of
course cooped up at home right now my
wife is a challenge she doesn't work I
work as a freelance so luckily I suppose
I work from home and luckily we live in
the countryside so we've got fields that
we can walk around and get out and about
and see see the the fallow deer and the
Marsh Harriers whom the rest of it you
know in the beautiful wildlife but we're
on the coast on the Adriatic coast but
we're not getting any money
Alan are you that and I'm fascinated
about our description of the Adriatic of
course finally just move your hand away
from the camera
for a minute Nicholas curry we've lost
you my last question my last question
would be this the the British media is
being slaughtered by the likes of Andrew
Neil by the likes of Piers Morgan for
the frankly supine weight that is
approaching government spokesmen and
even health and science spokesmen at
these daily press conferences is the
Italian media anymore tooth full than
the English media tooth fool yes I just
made that one up it's a good word is a
great word well done truthful in the
sense aggressive terrier like the
Italian press is bloody useless please
God it's a complicated subject but I
mean basically they don't get to the
point like British British the British
press gets to the point straight away I
assure you that that is not true
with the exception honourable exceptions
of Andrew Neil and Piers Morgan and
nobody else Nicholas we we lost your
feed it's been wonderful talking to you
hope that your family of six I shall
shortly have a family of six myself
survive and and thrive on the Adriatic
coast how many children I have five and
one on the way oh well done yes yes
we're we're both men men after each
other's hearts thank you very much
indeed
Nicholas Farrow let's take a quick break
shall we
radio Sputnik
tune in every Wednesday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker and John Kiriakou for
a regular segment called beyond nuclear
where Brian and John discussed nuclear
issues including weapons energy waste in
the future of nuclear technology in the
United States with Kevin Kamps the
radioactive waste watchdog and the
organization beyond nuclear listen on
Wednesdays right here on radio slurping
[Music]
want to talk get in touch with us at
radio at Sputnik news calm now this is
that was the week that was historically
it certainly was a momentous seven days
on this day in 1770 what is now called
the new world was discovered it kind of
had been discovered by the people living
there already but you know what I mean
on April 19th in 1770 Captain James Cook
spyder Australia the Aborigines of
course had been there for thousands of
years Cook was only 41 a mere lieutenant
and had been promoted to that only
because the British Admiralty wouldn't
accept that the ship HMS endeavour
should be captained by Scottish
geographer Alexander Dalrymple it wasn't
to end too well for the brave captain
who in 1778 became the first European to
visit Hawaii on Valentine's Day February
14th 1779 Captain Cook and his crew were
greeted with rocks shots were fired a
chief was killed and Cook was
peremptorily muddled by a charging mob
of locals five years after cook spotted
Australia the revolt against British
rule in the United States erupted in the
American Revolution the real Americans
having been largely parched beforehand
it began in Concord New Hampshire with
what is known as the shot heard around
the world but the years to follow were
to bring jazz rock and roll Presley and
Dylan and alarmingly Donald J Trump it
was also on this day
in 2011 that my friend Fidel Castro
resigned as first secretary of the
Communist Party of Cuba Central
Committee after 45 years also on this
day in 1995 a bomb at a public building
in Oklahoma killed 168 people including
19 children and injured more than 500
others Timothy McVeigh a 33 year old
Gulf War veteran was convicted of the
attack and sentenced to death by lethal
injection after a two-month trial he was
executed at Terre Haute federal prison
in Indiana on the 11th of June 2001 it's
funny I don't hear too many people from
the right in the United States
remembering that anniversary the Balfour
Declaration was recognized on April 20th
1920 when one country Palestine was
given away by a second country to a
third group of people who intended to
create a third country the ramifications
continued to this day and will likely
outlive us all on the 21st of April 1945
the Red Army captured the outlying
suburbs of Berlin at the beginning of
their taking of the city Hitler and his
mistress Eva Braun committed suicide in
his bunker on April 30th only hours
after they were married by May 2nd the
old German parliament building the
Reichstag had fallen a Marshall Zhukov
claimed the honor of being the Liberator
of Berlin on April 24th in 1916 the
Easter Rising about which we spoke last
week against British occupation began in
Dublin with the taking of the O'Connell
Street post office and the reading of
the proclamation of Irish independence
the rebels were eventually overwhelmed
and captured and most of the leaders
executed including the wounded James
Connolly the struggle continued
including a brutal civil war until the
Irish free
date - the six northern counties was
created in 1922 and became what we know
as Ireland today that was the week that
was and what a week it was now we'll
Boris Johnson survived after the
coronavirus 1837 votes so far you've got
half an hour left or so will Boris
Johnson survive a yes sixty percent B
know forty percent still quite narrow
don't you think Michael is in
Minneapolis got a Hyrum go ahead Michael
thanks George good good to be honest
always wonderful to hear your voice
again go ahead all right so I actually
have seeing some serious correlations
between UK politics and United States
politics that week yeah you know what do
the papers this for Queen people divided
by a common language Michael that's a
great way to put it
so essentially it came out this week
that the Democrats were running a
two-front a two-front offense so on the
one hand publi they were pushing the
state parties to hold the primaries joe
biden was was pushing for it publicly
DNC chair Tom Perez and Barack Obama
were pushing for it privately and now
we've had full workers die in Illinois
and Florida and we've seen an enormous
spike in Cova cases in Wisconsin which
was the most recent state that they sort
of bullied into having a primary with
full obviously with the Republicans
right on board pushing for the same
thing in ghoulish fashion even at the
same time they did that they came out
that behind the scenes Barack Obama was
conspiring to mount a public a PAC
against Bernie Sanders and somehow blame
him for people voting in the primaries
despite the fact that Bernie was
encouraging people to stay home even as
Biden and Tom Perez were demanding the
state hold the primaries and go to the
polls and as you know with with the
Corbin you know news that bombshell news
it's also come out you know over the
last a
nine months and little dribbles and
leaks that the entire party apparatus
you know what's working against Bernie
Sanders right up until you know Obama
orchestrated a full-out coup right
before Super Tuesday so we're sort of in
this position where we should have
jeremy Quarian and Bernie Sanders and
instead we have Donald Trump and Joe
Biden and I'm not sure either one of
them is totally coherent and I guess I'm
wondering what your thoughts on are all
of it well you're absolutely correct to
identify the mirror image of in fact
it's been going a long time Ronald
Reagan and Margaret Thatcher were a
mirror image of each other Bill Clinton
and Tony Blair were a mirror image of
each other and sir Kirsten Maher is only
a marginally less incoherent version of
Joe Biden and Boris Johnson only a
slightly better educated version of
Donald Trump so you're right and Oscar
Wilde's observation that we are two
people divided by a common language is
coming true with the increasing
frequency we're also the two countries
that will end up worst affected by the
corona virus we're the two countries
that will likely lose the most people to
the corona virus and probably were the
two countries whose performance against
the corona virus has been most pitiful
maybe we should join up again Michael
after all what could possibly go wrong
I mean I'm up for anything at this point
I just I don't it there was no way for
Bernie Sanders to lose this primary and
so now we as the whole progressive
movement or yeah I personally I work for
a political PAC that serves under the
Democrats so now it's my actual job to
try to elect Joe Biden if that's not the
most depressing part of my year I can't
even tell you what is well I wouldn't do
it I'm afraid I could not in conscience
ask people to vote for Joe Biden
I was hoping I'm not gonna vote for
myself but I also need to make rent and
the United States refuses to provide ubi
like every other well
I understand that dilemma but I was
hoping for a third-party run by Bernie
Sanders and if not by he than by tulsi
gabbard but neither of them is
interested in doing that who will be no
they're not who's the who's the green
candidate I supported their candidate
last time dr. Jill Stein is she going to
run again yeah yeah I voted for dr.
Stein as well last night I actually
voted for in 2012 as well unfortunately
she's not running this time and so it
looks like it's it's not for sure yet it
looks like it's probably gonna be Howie
Hawkins and Howie Hawkins is both a
Russia conspiracist and has said some
awful things about Julian Assange well
there's really no good place to go oh
well I don't have a vote but if I did
I'd be staying at home thanks Michael
in Minneapolis let's go to Yves in Idaho
go ahead Eve thank you to yours for
having me on
I wanted to tell you too two facts
I believe our heart factor and which for
me a bombshell in the story of
coronavirus the first one is an ragazzo
status - the first one is an assertion
by an Israeli I believe it's channel 12
in Israel saying that United States
toward Israel and NATO beginning of
November and this is crucial about a
virus having escaped from Wuhan the
second fact which is a bigger bombshell
and which I regarded true is that dr.
Mott and professor Montaigne who with
Nobel Prize in medicine Discoverer of
HIV said that the virus is made of a
corona virus which has been spliced and
by little pieces of HIV virus
that can be only done by a very advanced
laboratory and it probably come from
Wuhan so people asked him why he did it
if they well I don't know but it
probably happened in Bhutan and the
second thing is that there were probably
working on the vaccine so as hard as it
is the I think it's a good story I
believe that American and Chinese for
reason which are easy to understand were
working together on a vaccine against
the AIDS virus that's what dr. Madani
thinks they were doing and things get
wrong and then they share the blame but
at the end of the day you see it's not
the bioweapon I believe they were
working on the vaccine together and I
wanted to tell that to you because that
now the story I believe well I'm glad
that you did I already knew the story I
also think it is a highly credible story
it is certainly true that the United
States gave millions of dollars to the
Chinese laboratory in Wuhan under under
President Obama
they were joint sponsoring with the
Chinese government work on a vaccine I
also have heard that the Nobel laureate
said that the corona virus has been
spliced not just by HIV but also by TB
that it's that there are three items
present if you like in this tiny little
virus TB HIV and covet 19 and that
therefore means it was either released
accidentally or it was released
deliberately
by someone but I'm going to pressure on
something Eve if the United States
government and the CIA has said so if
the United States government was aware
of a release of this virus into the
atmosphere in November then that means
they knew before the Chinese government
knew that means they knew before anyone
else knew and were able to tell their
friends like Israel presumably Britain
the five eyes that this was so now how
is it possible that the American
government knew more about what was
happening in Wuhan than the Chinese
government did I think that's a very
moot point a very interesting question
and secondly of course it makes our
performance ever since all the more
lamentable because it turns out we did
nothing meaningful to defend our people
not from January to April from November
to April you see what point Eve yes no
you you are you're absolutely correct I
believe that American because we don't
know exactly I believe that American and
Chinese knew it together because they
work together but what the what you see
that firstly correct but the most
important thing for the world if to tell
the world that probably the Chinese
although American didn't conspire of
bio-weapon and World War three
they were working on a project which was
good for Humanity and went wrong this is
very very different that what you hear
everywhere it is a positive thing now
the response of the administration
has been terrible it is fair to say that
the Democrat didn't help him because you
know he was he was in the impeachment
time and all that so that didn't help
but the bottom line so I believe that
the Chinese and the American were
working together on a vaccine
okay easy thank you yeah thank you for
that we'll have trying get dr. Francis
Boyle on next week see his take on that
thanks Eve for that Peter in London he
knows where the virus came from so we're
about to take him go ahead Peter
evening George even example yeah there's
too much to evidence no to point I think
America in a very long game here they're
trying to take China down and China were
very foolish to have their military
games in Wuhan in the same city as a
level 4 lab and you know there's a
connection to this Benassi family that
just thickens and seconds today we find
out that this Benassi woman who wrote a
report for the Wellcome Trust on the 3rd
of October order it wasn't written
before that published on the 3rd of
October last year she is connected to a
transport companies that transports
biological weapons one of our members of
our family transports biological weapons
for the American army and another part
of this family is the one that a Chinese
assailant was in Wuhan in October
there's much more members of his family
someone who worked for Lockheed Martin
the one that was in Wuhan was driving
for someone that no runs Lockheed Martin
there's lots of diplomatic immunity
going on they're connected to NATO one
of the relatives is an nad nad reps and
the connection I found today in Brazil
is that she was working on cytokines in
satyr canes as what you know I don't
know if your your Angie Brucella has
been speaking about it but that's what's
killing people
the Americans have played a very long
dirty game on the Chinese here and it's
about time that the you know the
peace-loving people of this world start
getting their facts right so that is
idiots that Trump you know and whoever
else the mail Boris Johnson whoever are
just the ignorant people that think that
if chaining it took down they're going
to be slightly richer we need to start
talking about this and you know if we
were fighting the Gulf War the second
one this is ten times bigger George and
we really need a crack on this because
we're a long way behind the right
repress well thank you thank you Peter
send me any material you of God please
through social media I would appreciate
it
let me do some social media Dugan
Orlando says deep state knows time is on
China's site Rob Moran says that
Democrats are a huge problem for the USA
they are weak and much like the UK
Labour Party
whatever happened to their leader by the
way that circular stahma
see isolating their off more than he
could chew or what he's actually doing
more supportive work for the British
government's coronavirus response than
Michael Gove The Sunday Times and Sky
News funny old world in it
Zaki Chaudhary says the u.s. is
literally occupying the entire world
people are still pretending that Trump
is Hitler in the making and remembrance
rug guy says is social distancing and
act oxymoron antisocial seems like a
more apt descriptor and Neil curry says
hearing an ink hearing in English or
American going on about Chinese
mistreatment of Muslims is beyond irony
indeed it is the Reds are us George
supports all the oppressed thank you for
that
Derek says the government ministers are
acting little better than the generals
in World War one very good comparison
prepared to send the troops ie the NHS
staff into an environment without proper
protection while simultaneously praising
them it's time the generals went into
the hospitals let me take a quick break
Radio Sputnik we call Paul lines with
Nixon Stranahan the most disruptive
radio show in America it's a great show
and we have a lot of fun we come to you
live for Washington DC every Monday
through Friday morning what I like best
is that we bring in experts from all
over the world from Barcelona from Egypt
from Seoul South Korea from Newark New
Jersey we try to bring people great gas
great calls from our listeners and of
course stupid jokes and we do it with
two hosts that have very different
viewpoints now here's the thing Garland
a lot of people would think you and I
would just argue I mean I'm a Republican
trump supporter and of course I am a
progressive Democrat Bernie Sanders
supporter the surprising thing is how
much we actually agree on
you won't be surprised because you're
gonna find out just how much you agree
and just how much you enjoy this joke
the mother of all talk shows join our
faculty of legends contributors and
callers everyone is welcome now Governor
Cuomo in New York I heard on the news
has now made it possible for people to
be married online i suppose the the
officer of that might also be possible
you might be able to get divorced online
maybe you already can i don't know but
one thing is for sure it is testing
challenging for couples to be
permanently locked down together if they
don't have children they can have a
whale of a time I'm sure and the
maternity wards will be buzzing nine
months from all of this but if like me
you've got a lot of children in the
house then the mental health well-being
of children and parents is obviously a
very challenging thing to maintain
especially those living in small cooked
up accommodation especially those who
have nogada especially those who are
miles from the nearest open green space
and parkland so there'll be a boom I'm
sure in family and couple psychotherapy
and we've been lucky enough to get Tonia
Bostick one of the best family and
couple cycle therapists she's at the
private therapy clinic and she's here to
talk about how to cope with this
lockdown and I'm guessing that quite a
few of the viewers and listeners even if
they're pretending otherwise will now be
cleaning that little bit further forward
towards the screen or the radio to hear
what Tanya has to say
Tanya welcome to the mother of all talk
shows is a testing time this isn't it
yes it is George thanks first of all for
lovely words it is testing time I'm
afraid and
I assume that throughout the crooner
virus and afterwards we will have
academic studies to show as well what we
did in Corona Times yes I mean as I say
those it if you're on your own it's
going to be very lonely if it's you and
your partner you're you're quite likely
to be having a whale of a time but if
it's you and your partner with whom
you're no longer having a whale of a
time and even more if you've got all our
kids and ours and in the circumstances I
described it could be hell it well done
George well don't become Family
Therapist you're very experienced in
this I presume let me tell you I'm
similar to you I'm 48 as well now this
regardless of me being family therapist
I will quickly just go through a few
points what we can do regardless of
whether way a single whether we're
married couple or couple with children
first of all just few pointers George
one thing is being kind to yourself so
go to bed on time
sleep ideally 7 to 8 hours a day just
try to go to bed before midnight eat
healthily so try to have 3 to 5 healthy
meals a day supplement your you know
daily food intake with some vitamins the
minerals hydrate your body so this is
George what we can do on an individual
level even regardless of corona we would
still implement these measures now when
it comes to exercising some people as
you announced are lucky to have parked
nearby or some people are lucky to have
thread mills or bikes at home for those
who don't have them
ideally they can join some online group
what they can do yoga exercise this that
and the other so these are George CBT or
cognitive behavioral measures that
should be in place to help us get
through now let me just pinpoint quickly
that there are four basic emotions which
are fear anger
happiness and sadness so what do we do
in Korean at times the prime emotion is
fear if I live on my own most probably
that I will fear many things it that in
normal circumstances I don't fear so for
single people it's different bank
Partners partnership as you said nicely
with or without children can be a tricky
one
why we have facts and figures that
domestic violence and abuse the figures
for these things have increased last
couple of weeks why when you're in
confined space where you can't go to
work
you can't really exhibit things that you
that you used to doing there is bigger
chance that you might have a 2-fold it
does have two-fold effect on us firstly
we understand oh this part of a mine or
this husband is brilliant maybe I didn't
notice that before because I was busy
going to work doing different things so
that's the positive thing and I'm
noticing that you say miss BTC clinic as
a CEO dr. Becky Spellman we are positive
and we say yeah in corona times there
might be positive things however George
on the negative side many couples that
did have relationship that wasn't the
best and they were triangulating or
avoiding issues by putting them under
the carpet like going to work doing
different activities these things are
now gonna escalate and that is the
reason why we have more cases of family
abuse family violence and this is very
difficult now if we have children I have
them too and I did like your
introduction like in my personal
circumstance I'm happy because you know
when you have teenagers or all the
children they don't tend to sit at home
so again on the positive side family
dynamics might be nice because we get to
see more of our children we get to
socialize more however with families
with small children you know
godless or babies it can be more
stressed so if you ask me what are the
numbers we still don't know but for some
families it's going to be better for
some families it's going to be worse so
it's very very important to follow on or
on these family dynamics so what do you
think is going to be a busier a year
from now the maternity wards or the
divorce courts well optimistic
personally I would love to see more
maternity wards however there are some
figures like in China for example that
the number of the Box cases are
increasing so if you ask me personally I
would like the positive end of the
spectrum like my colleagues from PTC we
are positive we think along these lines
but I'm afraid George the future is not
that beautiful because many people will
lose jobs many people have already lost
jobs so the daily functioning is now
being jeopardized so if you ask me we
will see the figures released obviously
after covered is finished but I'm sad to
say that there might be more divorce
cases
yeah and suffering I mean we were
talking about the u.s. earlier 22
million people are now unemployed in the
United States getting on for within a
week it will be greater than the
percentage of unemployment in the Great
Depression in the 1930s it's quite
likely because when America sneezes the
rest of the world catches cold as they
say that the mass unemployment will
return not just in this country but to
other European countries and other
countries across the world and is hard
to be happy and well-adjusted when
you've lost your job and you're poor
isn't it Tania it's very difficult
George I am proud to be British but I
originally come from Serbia
I've been through 20 years ago when we
have the walls so you're talking to
someone who's been four five months in a
nuclear shelter so I may be the right
person to speak to because it is going
to be difficult now normally us British
didn't have major depressions and be
somehow quote but I very much fear that
even in these climate of today it's
gonna be difficult because many jobs are
being tested George and we are now
getting to see whether people can work
online many will lose jobs what an
impact on mental health will that have
what I like about Corona and basic
emotional fear is that it knows no
boundaries so whether you're black or
white religious non-religious labor
party whatever party never mind so
emotions wise we are the same but
economy wise we are not what we expect
psychotherapists that we will be dealing
with George is the greenest amount of
people having these existential issues
of being able to pay for mortgage pay
for food and therefore we expect the
bigger amount of people suffering
anxiety features depressive features
because fear on its own is just a basic
emotion that is with us and we should
embrace it however it girls can go up so
we get more anxious we get panic attacks
if fear goes to that extent that it's
overwhelming we start getting phobias so
these things you are discussing are just
a real-life issues many people will lose
jobs and therefore that might have an
impact on their mental health overall
how do you deal with with your
children's questions it depends what age
they are of course but for example I
have a five year old son my three year
old daughters not yet asking these
questions but my five year old ask me
every day because of course I have to
tell them when we are running playing
football for exercise stay away from
people and I have to shout
Livi's about to break those rules and so
on my five-year-old is actually afraid
of dying he hasn't said it to me but he
asked to his mother that he doesn't want
to die he wants to live and so on how do
you deal with that what should you say
to your children about the fear issue
well well done George good question now
let me tell you family therapy and
psychotherapy in general says
communication should be direct and open
it's up to children to raise issues so
if your child doesn't raise the issue
just gloss over it polish over it and
don't bring it up
if however some children's I can now
assess that your child that asked that
question means that your family is very
open and very direct so if your child
did ask this question we can only using
appropriate vocabulary for their age
range for example yours is 5
mine are 14 and 19 so obviously I will
adjust my vocabulary but fear of death
is a regular fear that does you know
live with us however George
we should really explain what we as mum
and dad think about it
and let them choose what that behavior
is gonna be why am I saying this I'm 48
my mum and dad never fear death because
there were medical workers so people in
my family for example I don't really
feel ill Nisour death because you know
all my life I'm living with it so my
attitude towards it is very open
acknowledge it but don't stress over it
some families might fear that they will
get ill that they might die so the best
you can do like any other topic feel
free to be open to express your personal
belief but let them choose what they can
embrace if it makes sense if you just
anya and finally
we've we've taken the approach of the
much ridiculed government of Malaysia in
that we are not going around in our
pajamas and and dressing gowns all day
we are we are as far as possible being
as smart as possible I'm even wearing my
makeup and my lip no you know what I
mean we are we're trying to look our
best and act as if this was a normal day
when of course it really is very far
from a normal day is that your advice
also I must say yes because George that
is CBT cognitive behavioral therapy that
means if you're in difficulty
you're not going to deepen that fear or
whatever you're feeling you're gonna
refocus a reframe you're gonna think
about something positive so that is the
CBT when clients come George is here and
now okay so I'm stressed about my
marriage I think it's going down the
drains what am I gonna do I'm gonna
refocus think about something positive
so I must say that it might sound
ridiculous but our psychologists
psychotherapists we try to find positive
even in negative x if it makes sense so
no I can't go to work and work working
from home but yes I'm gonna put me well
I'm now talking to you I have my hair
done and makeup so you know aren't
attending La market work
is it helpful for me yes it is so my
advice to be please try to see
regardless of coronavirus any issue you
look at try to be more positive try
always to look at your glasses being
half full rather than half empty if it
makes sense but then don't go as well to
cuckoo-land
because yes there are facts or figures
where we see that currently 16,000
people have died that we do have 120,000
people being
and positive for Karina so you know just
finding the right balance George in all
of these that's you know as always
Tanya Bulls each of the let me get your
clinic current private therapy clinic
ptc thank you very much indeed for
joining us now the pool is closed will
Boris Johnson survived a yes 60% be no
40% 2282 people voted the second poll on
which you can now vote who do you think
will win the 2020 US elections a Donald
Trump be Joe Biden you can vote now on
my Twitter feed my old friend fills up
from Ireland says I'm sure you're aware
of how wonderfully the Irish government
dealt with coronavirus when it hit the
world from your platform I would take
the opportunity to praise the Republic
of Ireland and Michael says New Zealand
is coming out of its summer cases will
increase as the northern hemisphere
decrease its pneumonic virus that likes
the colder weather as many viruses do
that's why we have epidemics of
influenza in the winter and Stuart in
response to the poll
suddenly Jones I had to vote yes to this
poll could you perhaps around a second
poll asking should Boris Johnson
survivors p.m. after coronavirus so that
I can vote no and Joseph by email says
I've been speaking to my niece tonight
who is a frontline nurse for the NHS
it's a disaster
no PPE no support no leadership from
either highly paid managers or the
government and James says covert 19 is
obviously all the news at this time it
would be good if everyone wants to stop
blaming one another Trump especially and
just work on getting testing kits PPE
etc but then you see James it's much
easier to try and divert blame and
attention uh
from your own utter miserable negligent
and criminal failure and on Facebook
Kathy says many of us have lived in
virtual lockdown due to disability
living in our world now we were the
hidden taboo families we exist now
powerful indeed that last point no
captain
Tom Moore who has walked with his Zimmer
up and down his garden so many times
he's raised 26 million pounds for what
was originally called NHS charities is
of course a hero who should be knighted
forthwith and I was I think the first
person in public life to say so Piers
Morgan who's got a much bigger ship than
me
took that up and he's done a wonderful
job in promoting the need to honor this
great British hero captain Tom Moore is
99 years old may god preserve them and I
hope we get a full Royal Air Force
flight past his house on his hundredth
birthday he's raised more money as a
single individual than I think any
person in history the question is how
did we get to the situation where our
national health service required ninety
nine year old pensioners to walk up and
down their garden and the great British
public to empty their pockets and their
pocketbooks to send to a charitable
cause
when the National Health Service is
supposed to be a vital national sinew of
our country now if it's for NHS
charities wonderful those lots of ways
that money can be positively used
constructively used but I'd hate to
think that captain Tom's efforts had
merely gone in to filling
a bucket with a hole in the bottom of it
of National Health Service funding we
need to mend the bucket we need to
properly fund the NHS we need to
properly tax the richest people and
corporations active and profiting here
on our island we need to look again at
whether we should be spending hundreds
of billions of pounds on trident
missiles and other weapons of war rather
than on the basics of keeping our people
safe healthy and alive I salute you
captain Tom Moore I may have been the
first in the land to do so I think
you're a national hero but I think the
people who so reduced us to requiring
you to make such efforts to have a
proper health service I'm not heroes but
villains here's the news with Jamie Lowe
curious about our curriculum have
something to say then call us now to
join the debate on the mother of all
talk shows with George Galloway tune in
every Tuesday to loud and clear for a
regular segment called false prophets a
weekly look at Wall Street and corporate
capitalism where we talk about the big
economic issues of the week from the
point of view of working people the poor
and the u.s. position in the global
economy join us this Tuesday and every
Tuesday with financial policy analyst
Daniel Sankey right here on radio
Sputnik
it's time to double down with Max and
Stacey yeah double down we're talking
markets finance business economics to
chang bling just about everything money
related on Sputnik it's called double
down we're asking our dead cats bouncing
or have fundamentals change that's this
week and double down
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news some of the biggest
names in music have joined forces to
celebrate healthcare workers in a
globally televised concert Lady gaga
Paul McCartney and Billy Eilish were
among more than a hundred artists who
performed songs from their living rooms
due to the coronavirus lockdown
The Rolling Stones even managed to play
together from four separate locations
the eight hour show also featured
real-life stories from those on the
front line of the fight against covert
19 Lady Gaga who curated the lineup
called the event a love letter to the
world title one world together at home
the concert was organized by the global
citizen movement and the World Health
Organization proceeds generated from the
concert or go to The Cove in nineteen so
Ladera t response Fund for the w-h-o but
Lady gaga made clear that the show was
not a fundraising telephone and would
focus on entertainment and messages of
solidarity however so far it's raised
more than 128 million dollars in Britain
BBC One is screening excerpts of the
concert and they will also introduce
extra performances from British artists
and stories from frontline workers in
the UK Spanish children who have been
kept at home since the 14th of March
under strict measures to curb the spread
of KO bida 19 will at last be able to
see the outside world later this week
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez aimed to
relax the lockdown rules on April the
27th so that they can get some fresh air
as he put it
Spain has seen more than 20,000 deaths
since the start of the pandemic and
almost 200,000 reported cases in a
televised briefing Sanchez said Spain
had left behind the most extreme moments
and contained the brutal onslaught of
the pandemic the number of kovat 19
patients who died in UK hospitals has
risen to 16,000 and 60 that's an
increase of 596 in 24 hours down from
the previous daily death toll of 888
however these figures do not include
those who've died in care homes or in
the community and are likely to be at
least
50% higher professor Sara Gilbert who's
leading a team developing a vaccine at
your Oxford University said that they
are hoping to start clinical trials
towards the end of next week but nobody
could be sure it was possible to find a
workable vaccine
she said that they would need government
support to accelerate manufacturing
because the UK currently does not have
the facilities to make the vaccine on a
large scale Germany's Health Minister
says that the month-long lockdown has
brought his country's coronavirus break
under control
yen span said since April the 12th the
number of recovered patients had been
consistently higher than the number of
new infections the infection rate has
dropped to naught point 7 that is each
infected person passed the virus to
fewer than one other in Germany three
thousand eight hundred and sixty-eight
have died of kovat 19 fewer than in
Italy Spain France and the UK New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo has signed an
order allowing online marriages as many
weddings have been cancelled under
lockdown restrictions from now on people
in the US state will be able to apply
for marriage licenses remotely and
carked allowed to conduct ceremonies
virtually Cuomo joked that the decision
meant that there was no excuse for
couples to not tie the knot the decision
comes after New York State extended
lockdown measures until May 15 more than
13,000 people have died of corona virus
in New York City alone Israel is facing
the growing prospect of an unprecedented
fourth election in just over a year
after a deadline two former government
has expired
its president passed the mandate to
Parliament after the center-left Locke
leader benny camp's failed to seal talks
to form a unity government in time if no
one else gets nominated within 21 days
new elections will be held by August the
fourth and finally captain Tom more than
99 year old who's raised more than 25
million for the National Health Service
in the UK by walking around his garden
has released a charity single which has
gone to number one in the iTunes chart
the track you'll never walk alone which
Tom Moore recorded with Michael Ball has
pushed Dane virile in and Katherine
Jenkins duets have Wilma
again to number two the 1945 rodgers and
hammerstein song from the musical
carousel will raise money for the NHS
alongside captain moore's ongoing
walking appeal it's become an anthem for
medical staff during the corona virus
pandemic the new version features an
introduction from Tom Moore who says
when you walk through a storm hold your
head up high and don't be afraid of the
dark more maybe 99 but the woman he beat
to number one Dame Vera is still alive
at 103 years old
the forces sweetheart Dame Vera had
entered the charts just a few days
before with the re-release of her
wartime inspirational song which first
came out in 1939
that's butt-nik news by Jamie Lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
the untold
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio now FRA in Allen sees
Romanian fruit pickers are flown into
Britain and Ireland amid a worldwide
pandemic putting their lives at risk and
their families at risk so farmers and
corporations can fill their boots with
money
it's simply despicable and kiten says
Boris will stay p.m. because even if
there are a few million deaths in the UK
there are enough Tory voting nutters who
vote for the men for the men no matter
how many may die and Kieran says Boris
is making treasom a look strong and
stable a Twitter user says held immunity
does work it's great for those that
survive perhaps not so much for those
that don't and there will be a lot of
those and jounin on response to our poll
says we'll see if there's a financial
collapse if there is one what's than the
Great Depression I doubt he'll survive
but then we'll probably get golf well
we've got much medic dr. Ranjit brah a
physician a surgeon and an all-round
sage not just on medical matters but on
Chinese matters his wife is Chinese he
has a close association with China and
so I'm going to ask him first up dr.
Ranjit thank you for joining us what do
you make of what seems to be a fairly
dramatic turn to blaming China is this
pure diversion or is there something in
the charge now that China is lying that
it lied in the beginning and that it's
still lying now thanks George pleasure
to be back with you on the show I think
this this turn is if you like turn back
to the original narrative we know
when this virus first emerged that
trumped that Johnson that the UK
government and the US government in
particular were very keen to throw
accusations around China initially
blaming it's a repressive society a
communist society obviously society that
didn't share information in fact you
know their own medical schools you know
a Harvard Medical School because a key
medical school the United States if you
look at what their virology departments
were saying they were saying at that
time that it was remarkable that within
two weeks of encountering an unknown
disease the corona virus infection that
they had recognized it as a new illness
a discrete illness that they had taken
samples genetically analyzed it and
found its genetic code and shared that
with the world that's a remarkable
achievement and that was the assessment
of US medical neurologists and academics
which totally undermines the current
narrative and the narrative that I had
at that time well initially there was a
blow-by-blow account in the media of the
rising numbers of cases in China but as
China brought it under control then
instead of like gloating over the extent
of disease in China it became suspicion
that we weren't seeing the real picture
it's quite clear that we are seeing the
real picture that china has got this
disease under control because of the
measures that it took and the World
Health Organization has been very clear
they sent a delegation along with
Europeans and Americans to verify and
assess the response to this corona virus
as early as late January and early
February and that report has been
released together with all the
recommendations recommendations yours
that we're still not taking and to me as
this is unfolding and we know in the UK
now have been 120,000 confirmed test
positive cases there'll be many more
cases 16,000 deaths during the lot last
week you know many days they were they
were close to a thousand deaths in
hospitals alone and probably as many as
2,000 if you add on to that deaths and
care homes and deaths in the community
and we won't know those true figures for
some time so as as this has unfolded as
day by day we've had promises of more
ventilators promises of more capacity
promises of sufficient PPE and it hasn't
and you know there's rising anger and
it's quite clear that China has scored
some very positive points in terms of
its PR because not only has it contained
the virus his own country issued very
timely warnings and have been very
transparent about the number of cases
and collaborated with John Hopkins
University for example to actually put
forward that live case tracker so we all
know how many cases there are all over
the world they have actually been at the
forefront of delivering aid together
with Cuba and other countries aid of
medical staff aid of their expertise
they've published in a summary of that
of just how to cope with this virus and
disseminated it and it really it's our
responsibility if we've not followed
that or more precisely it sounds
government's responsibility and I think
there's a very wide campaign which is
coordinated across the Western world
certainly between America and Britain
you know and labour and Tory have both
come out lauded diets published a
disgusting article when he said this was
he said the corona virus was china's
chernobyl and china should be held
accountable as if this natural
phenomenon there's no question it's a
natural phenomenon scientists are very
clear on that it's been published in
Nature magazine American scientists very
clearly that this wasn't a bioengineered
weapon this is a natural occurring
mutation of a virus which is any any
weight wide response circulation what's
disturbing about this virus is not its
enormous death rate though you know the
case fatality rate is high much higher
than the normal flu
it's his level of infectiousness
combined with a relatively high
mortality rate which means if it really
does spread as we're seeing you know the
fatalities can be frightening now are we
headed into the health immunity 2.0
because the government started with the
idea it's quite clear now not just from
what they said in public but what we now
know they were seeing in private that
their plan was that to let this run hot
to let it burn through the population on
the principle that probably by and large
only old people and already sick people
would would perish from it and that the
economy was the main thing
the pound shillings and pence trumped
the idea of your grandmother your mother
your father dying prematurely
are we back there again it certainly
seems that way George and it seems that
way I think because despite
protestations to the contrary as you say
we found out that really was the initial
plan both from you know lorises own good
morning interview later protested that
he hadn't had been interpreted correctly
but he quite clearly said that there
were discussions within cabinet and
within Cobra to the extent they should
let this run through the community and
subsequently we found out about his
chief adviser Dominic Cummings who very
explicitly said you know protect the
economy let it herd immunity and if a
few pensioners die so be it now what
really spurred the government to action
wasn't so much the health situation as
the collapse of the economy Black Monday
Black Friday
another Black Monday you know we've seen
a third of the value of worldwide stocks
wiped out within the space of a week and
ushering in a period when unemployment
figures are so high and they're very
massaged and subject to misreporting
really unemployment figures so it's an
area which you can to get a simple
figure is hard but many economists are
predicting that it we're going to be
looking at 25% rate if you look at the
economically inactive population it was
already 25% of the working age
population not working before this
crisis hit so it's very hard to work out
exactly what it will be but it will be
very high so protecting the economy
didn't work then suddenly apparently
realizing how many deaths that they
would be overseeing and directly
responsible for we went into a very
extreme lockdown but the things that are
necessary to get us out of lockdown will
precisely the things that we should have
been doing to avoid a general lockdown
but to take take focused targeted
measures and they remain
widespread testing we're currently out
of the half-a-million NHS staff we think
around 5% you know one in 20 NHS staff
have been tested I personally have had
symptoms I've had to self isolates and
then come back to work without ever
having a test and I'm by no means alone
in that situation so you know without
why's protesting we don't know where the
disease is we can't act appropriately
and how does one come out of lockdown
then without triggering again another
rise and we're barely plateauing but
still with very very many deaths it's
not even certain we've reached the worst
point and to come out of this we need to
go back to the straightforward health
measures of testing of isolation of
contact tracing and protecting the
population it's clear that we haven't
done that and precisely when we're
having promises that PP will be
delivered but it's not delivered then
the hospital staff are vulnerable then
infections can't be limited within our
NHS within our state of our hospitals
which as we talked about before a huge
over capacity you know that in the late
80s Britain had over 300,000 hospital
beds today we have going into the crisis
we had less than 140,000 beds as a drop
of over half in 2030 years and that
wasn't just because of increase in
technology day surgery all the rest it
was a deliberate policy to cut it we
have one of the lowest bed rates so we
have a low capacity rate we have six ITU
beds per hundred thousand of the
population the way we've expanded those
ventilators from the four thousand we
normally have up getting towards ten
thousand is mainly by decommissioning
everything that we do in theatres and
using those theater ventilators which
are not really designed for long-term
ventilation of ite patients but we're
using it and very slowly we're having in
dribs and drabs a few come here and
there allegedly some going to the
nightingale hospital but really the
entire effort to deal with coronavirus
has been marked by failure after failure
reassurance after reassurance upon which
very little has been delivered what do
you make finally and I'm grateful for
your time as always what do you make
about our country that claims that can
count the number of our old people dying
in care homes there is this thing that
was invented recently called the email
why can't the Department of Health email
every care home in the country and tell
them they want an email every morning
telling us how many people died of
coronavirus in the in the care home last
night why can't they do that what kind
of a country what kind of a rich country
cannot do that well I think it tells you
a lot about the priorities of our
government and of our economic system
and it is something which is revolting a
lot of people who are witnessing it of
course they're not absolutely sure what
people in care homes are dying of
because there isn't widespread testing
within those homes there was much talk a
couple of weeks back about the three and
a half million tests that would emerge
and testing would become much more
widespread there was a lot of talk about
getting testing up to 100,000 a day you
know testing went along with about two
or three thousand a for a long time
seems that it's got over 10,000 but
really these are pitifully small numbers
at this rate of testing it'll take the
best part Gorge of two decades to test
the whole country it clips it's quite
clear that this can't continue if we are
going to deal with this and come out of
the lockdown and one wonders what the
strategy really is at base they've
clearly given up with the idea of
question I mean either we're a third
world country being run by nincompoops
or they have no attention of mass
testing in the country it certainly
seems that way to me because the time to
institute this to avoid the damage was
as we were seeing in February the very
first cases coming to the country when
it would really would have been possible
to prevent this from running rampant
through the community but the initial
strategy which they outlined which is a
lesser fair strategy of really almost
amounting to
you know I hate to use the word but a
cull of our elderly and weak and and
vulnerable in society because these
people you can't make money from them
George and you know that the boudoir to
chromoly is someone who knows the price
of everything but the value of nothing
and they don't value the lives of
workers that they cannot exploit that
they cannot make money from and you have
to feel in the last analysis that this
is what is underlying their their
strategy and you know when they can
offer the working people nothing they
offer them hatred so they offer them
scapegoat so they offer them racism so
they offer them the scapegoats of China
and it does seem that there's a very
wide spread effort now to spread anti
Chinese propaganda and I've heard
Michael Gove issue words I've heard
leaders of the Labour Party issue words
and all of this talk mi6 have been
wheeled out the former leader of mi6 to
talk about you know totally changing our
attitude towards China so rather than
offer us medical care we're being
offered you know a direction for our
anger a deflection of our anger away
from our economic system away from the
privatization of our NHS which is left
it unable to cope and away from our
current leadership more clearly you know
failing in their duty to protect the
British people so thank you very much as
always dr. Ron G brought a wonderful
tour of the horizon-- let's go quickly
to the phones David is in Houston in
Texas no area on Joe Biden go ahead
David yeah you're watching New York I'm
sorry go ahead
how do you know Joe Biden is not it out
of brakes in the deep state I got a bad
section here in Georgia no I'm hearing
you how do I know how do I know Biden is
walk hello
yes David you're on the repeat your
question no how do you you're bad I'll
bring these day I think back to when I
call us back let's go Sean and Steven
Shawny there I am George go ahead are
you doing I want to talk about this
labor report yeah okay be sure you don't
break any laws when you're doing it very
best because it's hard not to burst a
blood-vessel that'll mention any names
fair enough fair enough I can't
understand why these people in the
governance and legal unit and being
drummed out the party I call understand
well they're not really in the Tower of
London
in fact floating down the river would be
my preferred solution forum because this
clear prima facie evidence here they've
undermined the elected leader of the
party and his policies they've
undermined electoral wishes and the
Democratic wishes of everybody that
voted him in which was a massive number
they basically subverted our democracy
here which they use they call people
that vote left-wing or support his
policies Trott's that's been language of
the nineteen fifties political
establishment in this country I thought
we'd gone past that we haven't gone past
that and of course that's was trance was
the kindest thing they said worked but
I've got a bigger question I think a
better one unless you're gonna tell me
that Jeremy Corbyn and John McDonnell
did not know that all of this was
happening I'm asking you why they didn't
do anything about it
ah well that's a very interesting point
as well because it's their governance
and legal unit so they must have known
the processes that are being run they
must have known the characters in there
and you can see from the report they've
actually accepted all the charges
against the likes of Livingston and
Williamson at face value they didn't
challenge him they just wanted to know
there would be an investigator's well
that's but that's a bigger scandal
there's no Shawn you can have rotten
apples in any organization and it's John
doar and Jane Doe
and people we never held off not much
political consequence but we're talking
about your leaders here if your leaders
are so bereft of the wherewithal to be
leaders in a way they brought all on
themselves and they you have to wonder
you have to win it because it's clear
from the report there was one person
making half of all anti-semitism
complaints and 1/3 of all the cases well
you see that one individual is that see
even I didn't know that one until I read
the report
why didn't Jeremy Corbyn go on the
television 500 times and say yes there
have been a lot of allegations but one
person made 50% of them yeah What did he
say that I'd like to know who paid that
one person as well well I probably
didn't need to be but why did not what
was that not the default answer to every
question on anti-semitism in the labour
party absolutely if we could spot that
why could me you should every money show
yours get anyone to answer thank you
very much Sean in Stevenage let me go
back to David in Houston Texas squared
David yeah George I got one for you
yeah excellent go ahead sir how do you
know that you're bad news and yeah I
love brain eBay I think Joe Biden is a
semi imbecilic senile man there's no
deep stay I'm aware of that would be so
bereft of hands that they'd have to that
have to be employing Joe Biden I think
how would you find al Tommy
they go on apology tour in Syria kind of
go to Russia and help them rebuild it's
a it's too bad evidence
too bad the line will need to let you go
I'm sorry for that wood I'm sure have
been an interesting call Mac says yes
Boris will survive they need him to get
breaks it done this time next year he'll
be gone
he was just a brexit p.m. no more no
less and Glenn says the Labour Party has
no one at all
who could beat Morris in a general
election that's a fact and they know it
that's undoubtedly a fact my question
was not hypothecated on labour beating
Boris Johnson but on the Tories
overthrowing him darin says he needs to
go his incompetence has caused far too
many lives to be lost and if he's
allowed to continue he'll cause many
more deaths Marcus says doesn't matter
what your political stance is whether
left or right Tory or labour Boris
Johnson's negligence is the biggest
dereliction of a prime ministers duty of
care in British history and he has to go
who do you think will win the 2020 US
elections Donald Trump 80% Joe Biden 20%
almost a thousand votes in you can vote
now on my Twitter feed when I come back
from this very short break it's the Hall
of Fame and the wall of shame
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
tune in every Thursday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker for the regular
segment called veterans for peace where
we focus on the contemporary issues of
war and peace that affect veterans their
families the country and the world as a
whole
veterans for peace president Gerry
Condon joins the show every Thursday
hear about this and more every Thursday
right here on radios button we are above
all the latest developments and we don't
take any sides radio Sputnik telling at
the untold
the mother of all talk shows with George
Galloway the world is our classroom and
you're welcome to sit in and join the
seminar I'm going to induct into the
Hall of Fame this evening one of the
most iconic extraordinary controversial
intriguing and I think significant
figures of the United States in the 20th
century I refer to Malcolm X Malcolm X's
original name was Malcolm little he was
born on May the 19th 1925 in Omaha
Nebraska something I never would have
guessed but he was assassinated on
February 21 1965 in New York City when
Malcolm was 6 years old his father the
Reverend Earl little a Baptist minister
and former supporter of the early black
nationalist leader Marcus Garvey died
after being hit by a streetcar thought
by some to have been a mother by quite
people in the town the surviving family
was so poor that Malcolm's mother Louise
little resorted to cooking dandelions in
the street to feed her children after
she was committed to an insane asylum in
1939 Malcolm and his siblings were sent
to foster homes
or to live with family members Malcolm
lived with his half-sister Ella
in New York and there he became involved
in petty criminal activities in his
teenage years he was known as Detroit
red for the reddish tinge in his hair he
developed all into a street hustler drug
dealer and leader of a gang of thieves
in Roxbury and Harlem in New York City
while in prison for robbery from 1946 to
1952 he underwent a conversion that
eventually led him to join the Nation of
Islam which can bind elements of Islam
rather quick shot
elements with black nationalism in order
to educate himself he spent many long
hours reading books in the prison
library even memorizing a dictionary he
changed his name to Malcolm X he founded
the Nation of Islam's newspaper Muhammad
speaks which he printed in the basement
of his home the nation leader Elijah
Muhammad had a special affection for
Malcolm X and named him second in rank
he preached on the streets of Harlem and
spoke incredibly at major universities
such as Harvard and the Oxford Union his
keen intellect incisive wit and
radicalism made him a trenchant critic
of American society he also criticized
the main stream civil rights movement
challenging Martin Luther King's central
notions of integration and non-violence
in 1963 Fisher's opened up between
Malcolm and Elijah Muhammad over the
political direction of the nation
Malcolm urged that the nation become
more active in the widespread civil
rights protests instead of just being a
critic
Malcolm brought additional bad publicity
to the nation when he declared publicly
that president john f kennedy's
assassination was an example of chickens
coming home to roost Malcolm X left the
nation in March 1964 and during his
pilgrimage to Mecca that same year he
experienced a second conversion and
embraced mainstream Sunni Islam adopting
the Muslim name el-hajj Malik el-shabazz
renouncing these separatist beliefs of
the nation he claimed then that the
solution to racial problems in the
United States lay in Orthodox Islam On
February 21 1965 Malcolm X was
assassinated was delivering a lecture
the Audubon Ballroom in Harlem three
members of the Nation of Islam were
convicted of the murder
but in 1992 the filmmaker Spike Lee
brought out the movie Malcolm X with
Denzel Washington playing Malcolm and
being nominated for an Oscar the point
about this and we're going to interview
on Malcolm X's birthday the author of a
remarkable book Black Thought black
thinking a history of the black acting
sorry black acting a history of the
political thought and its transition of
Malcolm X who started life as a criminal
hustler became a member of a black
separatist quixotic fringe element of
the Muslim religion changed to the
mainstream of the Muslim religion
rejected separatism and having earlier
condemned Martin Luther King in fact
began to politically advocate exactly
the same political line that the last
days of his life Martin Luther King was
doing in other words both dr. King and
Malcolm X were calling for black people
and Muslim people to join with white
people and non Muslim people in class
action against the exploitation of all
by the economic and political system
that obtained in the United States
Malcolm X and dr. King became from in
King's case purely civil rights activism
in Malcolm X's case an obscure branch of
civil rights activism both of them
became opponents of the Vietnam War
opponent
of the economic system of exploitation
of all and demanding the integration of
all against those responsible for both
of those crimes and many others
including the systematic discrimination
against black people in the United
States of America and just at that point
when both of them reached that point in
the transition of their thought and
their activism somebody somewhere
decided they had to be terminated with
extreme prejudice it's my belief that if
either both of them had stayed in the
ghetto of the previous levels of
activity and thought they would not have
necessarily been terminated they would
not have necessarily been mob don't but
when they did put all the pieces
together join all the dots together and
see the picture that emerged both of
them were cruelly killed and so it's
with pride that I enter the name of
Malcolm X into the Hall of Fame the wall
of shame given the hour I'll have to cut
short I'm entering onto the wall of
shame the British fascist leader Oswald
Mosley because of my my new book and I'm
now writing the sequel to it it's called
Black Lake
my first book called Queensway a deals a
lot with Oswald Mosley because of course
he was Hitler's Goleta
here in Britain he would have been the
prime minister of a Nazi occupied great
Britta and he would have carried out
exactly the fascistic best eality that
was visited upon the people of occupied
Europe because by then we would have
been part of occupied Europe ourselves
Moseley had been a Conservative MP then
a Labour MP then an independent MP then
a new party MP and ended in jail as the
leader of the British Union of fascists
a fifth column within our society
waiting to profit from the Hitler right
victory in which he fondly believed and
worked so hard to achieve
oswald mosley continued his fascist
activities long into the 1960s but he
was never the threat in the 50s and the
60s that he would have been in the
forties if Hitler had been able
successfully to conquer us he used
anti-semitism as a club to defeat
democracy in Britain he probably grew to
be ashamed of the things that he said
and did in the 1930s certainly his
children did as one of his sons put it
my father Oswald Mosley was with one
hand dealing with the most grandiose
ideas but with the other hand he was
setting the rat-free from the sewer
nobody could put any more powerfully
than that the heirs and successors
of Mosley ISM of fascism are still out
there of course though mercifully in
Britain we have a smaller problem with
fascists than virtually any other
country in Europe there is no fascist
councillor in Britain still less a
fascist MP wealth in many countries
there are fascists in the government in
the Parliament and in numbers in the
municipality but we can never let down
our guard
wherever fascism like Mosley rears its
ugly head we have to name it and shame
it for what it is the people of Britain
led by left-wing sympathizers to return
to an early phrase broke the back of
Mosley ISM as early as 1936 in the
Battle of Cable Street when a hundred
thousand people stood in that tiny
Street in what was my own parliamentary
constituency of Bethnal Green and said
they shall not pass and they stopped
Mosley and they stopped the black shots
god forbid that we should ever have to
stop them again I'm entering sir Oswald
Mosley yes he was indeed a sir on to the
wall of shame here's David in Halifax on
the line let's take a call from him
David welcome hello coach yes David
you're welcome you're on the air go
ahead yeah my question is after I mean
I've been on the left for a long time
and I've married yourself and especially
with Malcolm X can't believe that you do
the guys seem just their mothers making
the car that's made my
look at the left you tried to set up an
alternative party again to labor quite
right - but a history of them being is
born of despair whether it's social
salons what it's respect you know
whether it's tough to keep having left
groups falling out and leaving them and
then they're all snared and I think in
Corbin was going to do it all and that's
where everybody should be in in the
Labor Party I wonder what they've got to
say now stahma
so soon elected now to lead labour
whether they ashamed of themselves now
along the line in the previous projects
and whether you think after all this
when things settle down whether let them
learn any lessons from setting up
independent parties and splitting and
whether they will put their egos to one
side and stick together and all and give
to today's working class a party they
need well for the lack of labor well
thank you David I take self-denying
ordinance on these matters on this
platform not very legal reasons I'd be
perfectly legally entitled but out of
courtesy to the platforms that we are
performing on and the the people and
sputnik and RT who are making this
broadcast possible out of respect to
them I don't proselytize for my own
political party or goals here on this
platform however I will tomorrow night 8
o'clock tomorrow night at 8 p.m. on my
Facebook page and for members of my
political party by zoom by direct means
through the zoom process I will be
talking about the collapse of the corbin
project and I do think that everybody
who's interested in left-wing politics
should tune in to that whether you
support me like me whether you loved
Corbin or didn't
whether you're glad or sad that the
project has collapsed I think you should
tune in at least tomorrow night at 8
o'clock on my Facebook page George
Galloway official
and the subject of the talk will be the
collapse of the carbon project
I know carbon better than the great
majority of people I've known him longer
than almost anyone else I understand his
politics and why they failed I think
better than anyone else and I invite you
to see if I'm right about that at
tomorrow night David thanks for the call
Craig is in Glasgow let's hear from him
go ahead Greg good evening to you
keeping season yes so far so good Thank
You Craig and I was saying sir corner
Babu of an eight o'clock well just after
that you had a fellow from London who is
on a bit there the Scottish government
yes yes I am I think you know I mean I
would point that has been equally as bad
as the UK's response I am but I think it
potentially must because you know from
her point of view before the government
who has spent years pointing the finger
at everybody else but themselves for the
reason and that we find ourselves and
you know facing the situations that we
do um when I said there's no Desson
because we have to remember that you
know started an EMP can't I'm pointing
fingers of blame but actually but the
tellers they already have because of
this a beat the floor Scotland owned
before the ug made that an instant
certainly wheels had closed down there
still before um we had considered
closing Ellis dome um and you know it
comes from I'm you know thank you so and
we are not represented really by anybody
properly because we have a part it is
concerned by independence and in this
alone and I think this coronavirus
situation I honestly think parties in
the response especially because because
let's get I think they'll get one I or
nests and one eye on the fact that of
course next year we've got a Scottish
parliamentary election that they will no
doubt be beginning preparations for em
by the end of this year so I think
that's the a begger concern
which is Satan and frankly for if I
solve and to think about in that
situation and then you look at the
shambles frankly that's happening
themselves as well and you know it's I I
believe we live in the age of
incompetence right now start as a
politics is concerned an S pandemic has
displayed and an unfortunately fail we
for many people and but in the worst
possible way and but also for me it's
not just the politicians we don't have
an s country or settle in Britain as a
whole any real mainstream media aware
that is truly unbiased aim which means
the information people get I don't think
is here aim the vast majority of the
same for accurate information in Italy
I think wicked aim stations or programs
like yourself and other sort of fresh
media as you will yeah I mean we don't
see ourselves as as fringe media but I
take your point and I think I know what
you meant by that one of the reasons why
we have an audience every week of
between half a million and 1.1 million
the highest one that we have had is
precisely because the BBC and sky and
ITV are not to be trusted and nobody
does trust them sometimes people watch
them they can't have the mother of all
talk shows every night sometimes they
watch them and fall for it but the
critical mass is developing in this
country which says that our country is
deeply dysfunctional that it is run by
people who are not fit to run it and it
is reported on the people who are
running it inadequately incompetently
negligently are not being reported on
held to account by analyzed by either
the opposition and Scotland's case
worthless
- Labour Party and in the Westminster
case where is pierced armour or by the
so-called Fourth Estate the journalists
and broadcasters have performed if
anything even more miserably than the
politicians that they are supposed to be
holding to account thanks Greg
I couldn't have put it more eloquently
than you I won't try guy is in
stoke-on-trent let's hear from him
go ahead guy yeah creepy George Duke New
Zealand a Goff family in New Zealand
yeah the last time I checked they'd had
nine fatalities now I can't be any more
accurate my IT systems all gone down 48
hours ago they'd lost nine lives at this
well for the last three weeks every
person flying into New Zealand is
compulsory taken into quarantine for 14
nights
there's no there's no debate you are
taken into quarantine the government
that have commandeered though towels and
suitable accommodation and they're put
in there and they kept there and
monitored their pee and
she kinder afraid I'd say pronounces
yeah it's proving highly popular she's
done very well I wasn't you the feedback
we get is that yeah she's tough but
they're like and also and other things
she's done is she's caught all the
government salaries by 20 percent in
putting her on yeah including alone yeah
can I just say the country ought to be
looking at and trying to analyse is the
German German response now they've got
population of 83 million yes or more
people than us a European country like
us same kind of population densities as
us
yeah but they've lost 25 percent of the
fatalities which we've lost now I'm not
a doctor but I would have thought the
two main factors are one that they can
test in the region of our four million
people per week and
they are resourced in the rate of five
times greater than we are per capita so
for every for every one ventilator we've
got they've got five and that's not over
the country that's per 100,000 people
remarkable remarkable guy thanks for
that great call the hour is running
though Russia does in California let's
hear from him Russian welcome thank you
George and just following up with what
other accommodators have said about the
similarities between the the recently
leaked report about the Labour Party's
NASA nations by unelected members of the
Labour Party basically intending to
destroy Jeremy Corbyn and what we've
seen the United States were not only
2016 but now 2020 people within the
Democratic Party went out of their way
to derail Bernie Sanders efforts what we
see here is really actually very good
news for people on both sides of the
Atlantic because these elements are
finally being exposed
rather than thing being whispered by
people and rumor and strange discussions
it's now in the open just as the
Chilkoot report once and for all showed
that Tony Blair was Allah was deceitful
possibly and could be described by some
people as a war monger
now we have evidence that people within
the parties that we put all our energy
and all our thoughts and prayers with
are simply being derailed by individuals
who have different agendas and we
understand that that's not just limited
to the Democratic Party the Republican
Party the Labour Party the Conservative
Party the Liberal Democrats
and over again and it's about time we
had the courage using since I'm in Long
Beach so close to Mexico that we have
the cojones to finally cross that line
and address these questions in a civil
honest and open manner where we all can
get to a better more respectable place
fantastic call stay safe in in in
California Russia thank you
here is Yvonne in Austria let's hear
from her go ahead Yvonne hi George hello
how are you
nice to hear from you again I love that
accent that Austrian accent I wanted to
read actually something now I've asked
her loosened the whole actually the top
of this the leak here it's um and from
Vicki leaks and it's I've lost the top
of it to tell you what exactly it was
the conference that went on in France
and it's the messages that have been
cables from the cables that have been
written to the various countries that
were taking part in this conference is
about
supplier warfare and there's a message
in here to the French to say the u.s.
believes participants would benefit from
hearing about your experiences 15 China
and setting of the biosafety level for
bsl-4 laboratory at the Luhan Institute
provided by our biology from the Export
Control intangible Technology Transfer
perspectives so there's it's an email
from the US giving France a talking
point to tell the people at this file
discussion to tell them about how they
helped set up the rule and Institute of
biology yeah yeah it's a joint operation
and they're not gonna be able to wash
their hands on that when China finally
answers these these insults and slanders
they're not going to be able to avoid
the interesting upon thanks for that one
last call from Jerry in Crystal Palace
just because it's in Crystal Palace I
couldn't resist it go ahead Jerry hello
hello yes oh hi there how are you I'm
good you're on the air sir
okay thank you just a brief quick
question on like know your opinion on
the breakfast situation how do you make
a business and trade agreement with the
world in this situation well we've
already bracketed will be leaving I
think at the end of the year either with
our deal with the European Union of
which even more desperately needs a deal
than we do given the current state of
things both here and there
we must leave we voted to leave
Parliament has passed a deal that we
leave and so we must don't you think
Jerry of course but once we reach the
December deadline and we've actually
officially left where do you go from
there and on trade negotiators when
everyone's shut down and things are
going to be slow to take up again yeah
well I'm in favor of our deal but if we
don't get one I'm in favor of trading
with everybody on world trade to
organization terms I always have been
but if we don't get a deal we ain't
paying the divorce payment you can't be
denied a divorce and still be expected
to pay you can't be in the situation
where they expect us to fork out 40
billion pounds when we badly need that
money here to rebuild our country
rebuild our economy once we have left
unfortunately Jerry they are has
defeated us and can talk no longer it's
been marvelous for me
next week we'll go to deal with the
ragged trousered philanthropist so make
sure you've read it by next Sunday we'll
have an expert on and we'll have a
proper discussion about it come back
next week same time same place
[Music]